mais on n'a pas de comité d'hygiène et
de sécurité au Sénat pour les semestres
bien mes chers collègues mesdames
messieurs je vous remercie d'être venu
nombreux aujourd'hui au Sénat pour
participer à cette audition publique
contradictoire consacrée aux problèmes
de corrosion sous contrainte rencontrer
sur le parc nucléaire d'EDF je salue
collectivement les acteurs du contrôle
de sûreté nucléaire au travers du
président de l'Autorité de Sûreté
Nucléaire du directeur général de
l'Institut de radioprotection et de
sûreté nucléaire je salue également les
représentants d'EDF conduit par Cédric
lennonowski qui est directeur exécutif
groupe chargé de la direction du parc
nucléaire et thermique je rappelle que
DF est aussi un acteur essentiel de
sûreté nucléaire puisque l'un des
principaux fondateurs de celle-ci et que
la responsabilité première incombe à
l'exploitant
je salue enfin les représentants de la
société civile monsieur Yves Marignac
chef du pôle d'expertise nucléaire et
fossiles de l'Institut Negawatt ainsi
que Messieurs Jean-Claude delalombe
président et Yves Le redirecteur de
l'Association nationale des comités de
commission locale d'information
c'est l'une des particularités de
l'Office que
d'articuler sur un certain nombre de
sujets comme la sûreté et la
transparence dans le domaine nucléaire
une vision de long terme et une grande
réactivité chaque fois que l'actualité
le justifie ainsi depuis sa création il
y a presque 40 ans l'Office a consacré
plus d'une vingtaine de rapports
c'est-à-dire environ 10% du nombre total
à des sujets touchants de près ou de
loin au contrôle de la sûreté de la
sécurité nucléaire ou de sa transparence
l'audition aujourd'hui s'inscrit donc
dans une continuité puisque l'Office a
déjà abordé le sujet de la corrosion
sous contrainte à l'occasion de
l'audition annuelle du président de
l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire le 17 mai
dernier puis de celle du directeur
général de l'IRSN le 18 juillet audition
au cours desquelles tous deux ont appelé
l'attention de la représentation
nationale sur les anomalies qui nous
intéresse aujourd'hui
avant de céder la parole à notre premier
vice-président le sénateur Gérard
Longuet je rappelle que cette audition
publique contradictoire est diffusée en
direct sur le site internet du Sénat que
la vidéo que la vidéo sera ensuite
disponible à la demande sur les portails
des deux assemblées et que le public et
la presse peuvent poser des questions au
travers de la plateforme accessible à
travers du lien fourni sur les sites
internet de l'Assemblée nationale et du
Sénat et bien sûr les nombreux collègues
parlementaires qui sont présents
aujourd'hui pourront également aborder
l'ensemble des des questions qu'ils le
souhaitent je laisse donc la parole au
premier vice-président Gérard Longuet
oui merci monsieur le Président merci
cher Pierre en qualité de sénateur il me
revient de vous accueillir dans ces
bâtiments qui sont aussi majestueux que
peu pratique et vous pouvez le mesurer
certains sont assis confortablement à
peine d'autres moins mais tous vous
allez souffrir la fois de la chaleur et
d'une présentation de documents
accessible certes mais parfaitement
perfectible ce qui prouve que nous
pouvons parler de technologie sans pour
autant la maîtriser dans notre usage
quotidien ça nous interdit pas de
d'assumer nos responsabilités parmi nos
responsabilités il y a celles qui con
qui consiste à informer à travers la vie
parlementaire celle de l'Assemblée
nationale et celle du Sénat nos
compatriotes sur un certain nombre de
réalité scientifiques pour en quelque
sorte donner l'état de l'art alors tu as
souligné que nos rapports sont souvent
orientées sur les questions nucléaires
c'est en partie l'origine de l'office
parlementaire et c'est ça ça raison
d'être quand il est vrai que ce choix
qui est un choix constant et dont les
les traces sont anciennes depuis la
Quatrième République sur l'énergie
nucléaire dans notre pays y compris les
déclarations de Pierre Mendès France que
j'aime est situé pour citer non pas que
je sois mon désiste convaincu mais c'est
montrer la continuité de notre de la
volonté nationale d'assurer à notre pays
une indépendance énergétique dans la
mesure où nous étions privés et
d'énergie fossile une fois qu'on a dit
ça force est de reconnaître que nous
avons extraordinairement progressé en
termes de transparence en matière de
connaissances scientifique et en
particulier dans le secteurs de
l'énergie en matière de connaissance
nucléaire cette transparence qui a
parfois inquiété ce manque se
transparence dans le manque aurait
inquiété nos compatriotes aujourd'hui je
honnêtement qu'il y a un accès à
l'information qui est rassurant et qui
permet de débattre entre nous l'avons
fait d'ailleurs récemment sur le sujet
de flamant ville c'était il y a près
deux ans maintenant plus de 2 ans
maintenant
nous avons eu l'occasion en 2016 de
parler de métallurgie sur la métallurgie
des cuves à certains que tout était
réglé mais en tous les cas on en a parlé
et un ça permis à la fois de dissiper et
des excès d'inquiétude et ce qui aurait
pu être considéré comme une certaine
indifférence donc nous avons à cœur de
mettre ces sujets sur la table et de les
rendre accessibles c'est le cas
aujourd'hui de ce problème des
soudures de cette corrosion sous
contrainte
[Musique]
les questions mais elles sont
relativement simples dans quelles
conditions s'écorgions sous contrainte
ont-elles pu être identifiées pourquoi
ne l'ont-elles pas été plutôt il y a des
réponses j'en suis absolument convaincu
force et de reconnaître et tant mieux
que la
science progresse que la connaissance
progresse et notamment l'évaluation
[Musique]
de la structure même de ceux qui nous
entourent et par conséquent la
satisfaction est à l'horizon c'est à
dire sur une ligne fictive qui recule
chaque fois qu'on avance parce que
justement on maîtrise mieux la
connaissance de telle ou telle sujet
Quelle est l'origine
leur ampleur leur gravité vous
appartiendra de de nous donner vos
points de vue respectifs et comment les
contrôler réparations nécessaires
vont-ils être réalisés quel sera leur
durée ça la question de la durée
fondamentale parce que nous sommes je
crois autour de 300 teravatts pour la
production annuelle du nucléaire
français c'est manifestement insuffisant
et il y a une attente qui a une
dimension de politique nationale et
européenne considérable les
parlementaires ont besoin de savoir
quelle est la probabilité de la durée
des difficultés
sortir des difficultés pour combien de
temps donc quelle garantie offre les
contrôles et quelle garantie offre les
réparations
contre la maîtrise de cerise et
évidemment la question c'est et derrière
cette montagne cette colline y a-t-il
une montagne que de la colline nous
cacherait-elle c'est exactement le sujet
qui nous rassemble je dois vous indiquer
que je pars je vous présente des excuses
parce que ce sujet me passionne mais il
se trouve que le Sénat dans son extrait
d'activité a mobiliser la commission des
affaires économiques pour visiter le
site du futur centre d'enfouissement de
gestion couchéologique profonde des
déchets nucléaires fortes activités vie
longue de 6 Go à Bures dans la Meuse et
que vous comprendrez que j'ai
l'obligation d'accueillir c'est les
sépare le ses collègues sénateurs
sachant que ministre de l'Industrie en
1993 et 94 j'ai accepté de ne pas me
résigner à la formule pas dans mon
jardin puisque c'est dans le jardin de
la Haute-Marne cher Bruno Sido et de la
Meuse que se trouve le futur centre de
gestion et des longues je vais expliquer
au collègues sénateurs comment nous
avons survécu à aux tensions naturelles
et légitimes que suscite la perspective
d'un tel projet
sont lequel nous ne parions nous ne
parlerions pas de nucléaire mais nous
parlerions de fin du nucléaire s'il y a
une perspective de continuité c'est
parce qu'il y a quand même des citoyens
qui acceptent d'assumer leur part de
responsabilité au service d'une forme
d'énergie qui a assuré à notre pays et
qui assurera j'en suis convaincu à notre
pays de l'indépendance de la
décarbonation et par conséquent des un
bonheur collectif dont je me félicite
mais je m'enfurai à cause de cela
monsieur le Président non vous serez
tout excusé monsieur le sénateur
personne n'a le don du biquuité et vous
continuerez même vous vous continuerez
évidemment vos activités
extras au texte également sur sur le
site de de burjeu laisse maintenant la
parole à Cédric les 22 skis directeurs
exécutif du groupe chargé de la
direction du parc nucléaire et thermique
pour nous éclairer sur ces questions ces
attentes que nous avons avec une
présentation d'une douzaine de minutes
environ pour qu'on puisse ensuite céder
la parole aux autres intervenants
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
vice-président mesdames Messieurs les
parlementaires mesdames messieurs je
vous remercie de nous donner
l'opportunité de nous exprimer devant
vous vendre de l'Office parlementaire
d'évaluation des choix scientifiques et
technologiques sur un phénomène inédit
inattendu celui de la corrosion sous
contrainte des tuyauteries des circuits
auxiliaires du circuit primaire
phénomène qui aujourd'hui vous le savez
perturbe le fonctionnement de notre parc
nucléaire mon exposé nécessairement un
peu technique aura pour objectif de
retracer les différentes étapes qui nous
ont permis de comprendre le phénomène et
bien sûr de le traiter alors tout
d'abord un rapide historique c'est à
l'automne 2021 lors de la visite
décennale du réacteur de sivo 1 dans la
Vienne qu'à l'occasion de contrôle
réaliser dans le cadre de cette arrêt
programmé nous découvrons des
indications dans les indications c'est
un signal anormal atypique sur des
portions de tuyauterie des circuits
auxiliaires du circuit primaire sur le
circuit d'injection de sécurité risques
c'est un circuit de sauvegarde qui est à
l'arrêt en fonctionnement normal mais
bien sûr qui a pour fonction d'injecter
de l'eau dans la cuve du réacteur en cas
d'accident par exemple en cas de brèche
dans circuit primaire c'est donc un
circuit très important pour la sûreté du
réacteur la portion de tuyauterie ou
sont détectés ces indications et celle
qui est directement connectée au circuit
primaire avant le premier organisme
d'isolement c'est-à-dire avant la
première vanne de ce circuit
quelques ordres de grandeur pour vous
éclairer
sur les dimensions de ces tuyauterie
elles font environ 30 cm de diamètre et
l'épaisseur du métal est de 3 cm et la
longueur totale des portions de circuit
est de en moyenne d'une dizaine de
mètres
donc lors de chaque visite décennale sur
tous les réacteurs du parc nucléaire
nous effectuons des contrôles sur ces
tuyauteries afin d'y rechercher
d'éventuelles défauts et notamment le
phénomène dit de fatigue thermique la
fatigue thermique c'est un mécanisme
d'endommagement induit par des
fluctuations répétitives de la
température liées par exemple à la
présence de tourbillons d'eau chaude à
l'entrée du circuit pour rechercher ce
type de défaut nous effectuons des
contrôles par ultrason c'est-à-dire au
moyen d'un appareil qui envoie des ondes
sonores dans la tuyauterie et c'est par
la lecture et l'analyse complexe de les
cours envoyés c'est un signal lu sur un
écran que nous pouvons déterminer s'il y
a des faux autrement dit une fissure
dans le métal
fin 2021
j'y reviens nous détectons par cet
appareil à ultrasons des indications sur
les tuyauteries de civo 1
mais qui clairement ne correspondent pas
de la fatigue thermique nous découpons
ces portions de tuyauterie pour les
remplacer et les expertiser dans notre
laboratoire holiday à chinois et donc
c'est là à notre grande surprise que
nous découvrons qui ne s'agit pas de
fissures justement initié par la fatigue
thermique mais bien par de la corrosion
sous contrainte et il s'agit de fissures
de taille significative puisqu'elle font
5 à 6 mm de profondeur sur toute la
circonférence de la tuyauterie elles se
sont développées dans le métal à
proximité des soudures pas dans les
soudures mais à proximité des soudures
alors un petit arrêt sur image momentané
sur la corrosion sous contrainte la
corrosion sous contrainte c'est une
fissuration progressive qui est fondée
sur une interaction entre un matériau
ici un AC inoxydable assez classique dit
316L un environnement là c'est l'eau qui
passe dans ce tuyau qui a évidemment des
composants chimiques du bord du lithium
de l'hydrogène et une sollicitation
mécanique qui peut provenir soit de
contraintes résiduelles du soudage
initial soit de sollicitations mécanique
lors du fonctionnement même de ce
circuit
ce phénomène est donc bien le résultat
d'interactions complexe entre ces trois
dimensions avec des paramètres qui
influent plus ou moins
nous avons déjà rencontré à la fin des
années 90 des premiers cas de
fissuration par CSC d'acier inoxydable
mais ces cas étaient liés en général à
une pollution qui avait été
identifiée lors des expertises et bien
sûr un recensement alors par zone a été
effectuée sur la base des connaissances
de l'époque et aucun risque d'apparition
de corrosion sous contrainte n'a alors
été identifiée sur les lignes
auxiliaires dont les lignes riches dont
je parle à l'instant entre la connexion
sur le circuit primaire et la première
vanne d'où le caractère inattendu de ce
que l'on découvre à Civaux
la seule situation similaire que nous
ayons repéré dans le monde entier se
trouve au Japon dans la centrale Dohy
réacteur do i3 et vu en 2020 avec la
détection de corrosion sous contrainte
sur une tuyauterie en milieu primaire
effectivement sur un acier inoxydable
assez proche de l'acier dont nous
parlons à Civaux alors j'y reviens les
résultats des contrôles effectués à
Civaux et la nature des défauts relevés
nous conduisent alors à mettre
immédiatement à l'arrêt le jumeau le
réacteur de Civaux 2 pour y réaliser les
mêmes contrôles nous y détectons des
défauts similaires et donc dans la
foulée à titre de précaution nous
mettons également à l'arrêt les deux
autres réacteurs du même palier dit M4
les deux réacteurs de chaud dans les
Ardennes vous le savez la sûreté AEDF
est une prière était absolue n'y est
donc pas de débat entre nous nous devons
arrêter les réacteurs dans lesquels la
corrosion sous contrainte est identifiée
un autre événement survient alors en
parallèle sur le réacteur de panli 1 lui
aussi en visite décennale au cours des
contrôles programmés lors de cet arrêt
une indication est relevée à nouveau sur
une tuyauterie d'injection de sécurité
ris les expertises réalisent dans la
foulée montrent qu'il s'agit également
de corrosion souvent crainte nous
comprenons alors que ce n'est pas
seulement le palier N4 qui est concerné
mais l'ensemble du palier du parc
nucléaire pardon qui est potentiellement
concerné nous sommes donc bien
confrontés à un défaut générique
la réglementation française est claire
et notamment l'arrêté du 10 novembre
1999 relatif à la surveillance de
l'exploitation du circuit primaire
principal de nos réacteurs dans une
telle situation le maintien en service
de défaut de cette nature ne peut se
faire qu'après une instruction technique
longue et approfondie et il nous est
apparu que seul la réparation des
défauts rencontrés étaient à privilégier
pour assurer un retour rapide des
réacteurs sur le réseau nous avons
établi alors une stratégie de contrôle
qui vise à avoir aussi rapidement
possible une vision précise de l'état de
notre parc une stratégie qui est basée
sur deux piliers on a à la fois défini
des réacteurs témoins par palier et puis
surtout effectuer une relecture a
posteriori de l'ensemble des contrôles
réalisés ces 10 dernières années sur
l'ensemble des réacteurs du parc
suite à ces travaux ce sont 7 réacteurs
supplémentaires qui vont être mises à
l'arrêt en complément des 4 N4 et de
Pandi 1 nous retrouvons ici les 12
réacteurs dont vous avez tous entendu
parler au cours du premier semestre 2022
en raison de ce problème nous équipes
ont du réaliser ces contrôles par
ultrasons seul dispose disponible à
l'époque qui a des limites comme je vous
l'ai dit puisqu'il n'est pas prévu pour
trouver de la corrosion sous contrainte
mais bien de la de la fatigue thermique
il n'est donc malheureusement pas mesure
de préciser la nature la profondeur des
indications relevées et c'est pour ça
que nous n'avons pas d'autre choix que
de procéder à des découpes de portion
tuyauterie qui sont alors déposées pour
être transférées à Chinon dans le
laboratoire du Guidec ce sont donc de
nombreux chantiers de grande ampleur qui
commence au total sur le premier
semestre 2022 ce sont 115 soudures
différentes qui ont été expertisé avec
des équipements de laboratoire de haute
technologie 230 échantillons
métallographiques ont été analysés avec
des microscopes de grandes précisions
alors c'est l'ensemble de ce travail
d'expertise
titanesque qui nous permet d'avoir
aujourd'hui une relative bonne
compréhension du phénomène et notamment
de pouvoir raisonnablement affirmé
premier point le caractère prépondérant
d'apparition de la CSC est la géométrie
des lignes des circuits auxiliaires
parce qu'elles détermine le niveau de
contraintes rencontrées dans les
tuyauteries
deuxième point les réacteurs de 900 MW
c'est-à-dire 32 réacteurs et les
réacteurs de 1300 MW du palier P4
c'est-à-dire 8 réacteurs sont peu ou
très peu sensible à la corrosion sous
contrainte
en revanche c'est le troisième point les
réacteurs de 1300 mégawatts de type P
prime 4 c'est à dire 12 réacteurs et les
réacteurs N4 sont sensibles ou fortement
sensibles à l'apparition de la corrosion
sous contrainte il ressort également de
nos analyses que la zone de tuyauterie
dans laquelle le phénomène apparaît et
délimité par une soudure au-delà de
laquelle la corrosion ne se développe
plus tous ces éléments combinés avec des
analyses de sûreté et des calculs de
tenues mécaniques des tuyauteries nous
ont permis de présenter à l'Autorité de
Sûreté Nucléaire le 13 juillet dernier
un dossier complet comprenant à la fois
notre analyse ainsi qu'une stratégie de
contrôle et de réparation pour
l'ensemble de nos réacteurs je laisserai
bien entendu le président de la SN
s'exprimait sur cette stratégie
alors par rapport à votre question sur
le sénateur Longuet ou en sommes-nous
aujourd'hui
sur les douze réacteurs 10 on fait ou
font l'objet de réparation des circuits
qui ont été déposés
alors deux d'entre eux évidemment sur
les 12 mérite un petit commentaire tout
d'abord flamant vilain ou une opération
majeure de remplacement de général de
génération
de générateur de vapeur est en cours et
les deux opérations ne peuvent pas être
menées de concert donc nous y viendrons
plus tard nous espérons comme il s'agit
d'un réacteur du palier P4 ne pas
découvrir de corrosion sur cette
tuyauteries et puis budget 3 qui est un
réacteur du palier 900 MW donc moins
sensible au phénomène de corrosion ou
suite notamment aux résultats des
expertises de buge 4 et de Fessenheim
qui nous montrait aucune trace de
corrosion sous contrainte nous avons
décidé avec l'accord de la SN de ne pas
procéder à des écoutes à des découpes
pour expertise donc je reviens aux 10
chantiers de réparation 6 sont
aujourd'hui terminés permettant le
retour de ces réacteurs sur le réseau
pour l'hiver qui vient
un autre chantier à panlien devrait se
terminer courant novembre et notre
objectif qui reste atteignable et que
les trois derniers chantés savoir les
deux réacteurs de chaud et le réacteur
de Civaux soit terminé d'ici la fin de
l'année il convient de noter qu'à la fin
d'un chantier CSC il peut rester un
certain nombre d'activités à réaliser de
plus ou moins grande ampleur
un point qui n'est pas de détail sur ces
réparations puisque la question nous est
souvent posée nos procédés sont basés
sur des modes opératoires semblables à
ceux utilisés à l'origine principalement
parce que ces procédés ont alors fait
l'objet d'une qualification et que
évidemment en si peu de temps il serait
impossible de qualifier de nouveaux
procédés néanmoins nous apportons des
améliorations sensibles et surtout nous
allons contribuer à travailler dans ce
sens là la bonne réalisation de ces
chantiers et le résultat d'une
mobilisation de plusieurs partenaires
industriels qui sont engagés à nos côtés
depuis l'origine je voudrais ici les
remercier il s'agit de Monteiro et son
partenaire honnête qui ont fait un
travail remarquable à six vaut 1 à
Tricastin 3 et qui sont aujourd'hui
concentrés sur si vos deux et chaud 2
Endel qui a rapidement terminé un
premier chantier à Chinon B3 et qui est
aujourd'hui mobilisée à panlien et par
ailleurs avec si j'ai dit on était tout
à fait remarquables à cattom 4 enfin les
deux chaudies Framatome et Westinghouse
qui sont présents sur les chantiers de
buge 4 Flamanville 2 et showin il nous
apporte leur expertise technique ainsi
qu'une dimension internationale a été
beaucoup évoquée avec la sollicitation
de soudeur venus notamment d'Amérique du
Nord des industriels évidemment que
j'aurais souhaité plus nombreux ou avec
des ressources plus importantes non
seulement pour pouvoir aller plus vite
sur ces chantiers mais aussi pour des
questions de radioprotection afin de
minimiser la dosimétrie intégrée par
ceux qui travaillent sur ces chantiers
dans le respect de la réglementation
bien entendu nous sommes en passe grâce
à eux de tenir notre objectif de
remettre ses réacteurs sur le réseau
pour le prochain hiver
par ailleurs je tiens à souligner que
dès le début de l'année 2022 nous avons
mobilisé des fondeurs et des forgerons
italiens avec qui nous avions l'habitude
de travailler dans le cadre du programme
grand carénage cette mobilisation a été
très efficace puisque au bout de 6 mois
nous avons eu toutes les pièces de
rechange pour réaliser les travaux de
réparation programmées
cette anticipation des besoins dès le
début de la crise a été un élément clé
de sa résolution au vu de la situation
actuelle nous sommes encore en mesure je
le répète de respecter les objectifs
fixés par le responsable d'équilibre RTE
pour le prochain hiver
voilà pour l'urgence un petit mot de ce
qui vient maintenant puisque l'une de
vos questions monsieur le sénateur
Longuet était celle de la durée de la
perspective le dossier n'est pas clos
c'est évident en premier lieu et
conformément à l'engagement que nous
avons pris vis-à-vis de l'autorité de
sûreté nucléaire nous allons procéder à
des contrôles sur l'ensemble des
réacteurs les plus sensibles donc le
palier de P prime 4 et ces contrôles
sont déjà engagés sur quatre noms
golfechin et panli 2 et il le seront sur
les autres réacteurs l'année prochaine
bien sûr et en fonction des résultats de
ces contrôles nous procéderons ou non à
des réparations
j'en profite pour faire une incise sur
les moyens de contrôle je vous l'ai dit
à quelques minutes jusqu'ici on avait un
moyen qui était lié à une autre
recherche la fatigue thermique il a
fallu développer un nouveau dispositif
c'est une vraie prouesse que d'avoir
développé en moins d'un an
une nouvelle technique de contrôle par
ultrason qui est déjà de très grande
qualité puisque une capacité de sonder
justement ces trois centimètres de
d'épaisseur de métal je tiens là aussi à
saluer tous ceux qui ont travaillé sur
cet outil qui n'est pas encore parfait
mais dont on pense pouvoir vraiment
disposer totalement à partir du début de
l'année prochaine et donc nous éviter
des découpes complémentaires
par ailleurs même si nous avons à ce
stade une compréhension assez fine du
phénomène nous sommes également
conscients qui restent encore beaucoup
d'efforts de R&D amener pour décrypter
tous ces mécanismes complexes pour nous
aider
pour nous éclairer nous avons réuni au
début du mois d'octobre 15 experts
venant du monde entier des experts de
métallurgie nous leur avons transmis de
nombreux documents sous confidentialité
bien évidemment
nous avons été auditionnés les uns et
les autres et il
prit un certain nombre de
recommandations qui vont nous être très
utile
nous avons évidemment interrogé sur le
bien-fondé de notre analyse et de façon
unanime ils ont dit partager nos
conclusions mais ils nous ont également
demandé d'approfondir certains sujets
c'est ce que j'évoquais il s'agit par
exemple de la température du circuit qui
sans doute un facteur important mais
également du taux d'oxygène dans ces
mêmes circuits sujets pour lesquels nous
allons lancer des campagnes de mesure
les experts ont également donné un avis
favorable sur le nouveau dispositif de
contrôle ultra sonore que j'évoquais à
l'instant et qui va être très important
enfin tout en soulignant le bien fondé
des remplacements de tuyauterie à
l'identique parce que c'était des styles
la meilleure solution pour amener les
tranches le plus vite possible
pour autant ils ont indiqué que dans
leur pays pour certains des solutions de
type pardon de langue glycis mais il est
pas vraiment de traduction française
d'overley était utilisé en fait c'est un
dispositif qui consiste en la joue à
l'extérieur de la tuyauterie d'un
dispositif métallique sous des sur la
tuyauterie elle-même à l'endroit une
fissure est présente c'est un dispositif
qualifié selon les codes et normes
américaines dit asmé eDF va examiner
bien sûr la pertinence de ce type de
solution et engagé un dialogue avec la
SN sur le sujet
oui alors le mot qui va beaucoup
déplaire aux spécialistes qui est
souvent utilisé c'est manchonage validé
voyez c'est l'idée du manchon qui vient
voilà mais l'idée c'est bien d'ajouter
une couche complémentaire pour couvrir
la fissure et la protéger momentanément
donc après cette phase d'urgence nous
passons donc comme je vous le disais à
l'instant à une seconde phase qui vise à
réaliser des contrôles et des actions de
recherche de plus long terme c'est un
programme de plusieurs années qui
s'ouvrent devant nous certes les impacts
sur la production devrait être de plus
en plus faibles au fil des mois
heureusement mais il va encore mobiliser
beaucoup de temps et beaucoup de monde
en conclusion je souhaiterais vous faire
part de trois éléments qui ont été un
fil directeur pour nous tout au long de
l'année qui vient de s'écouler le
premier qui ne vous surprendra pas la
sûreté nucléaire a été et demeurera
notre priorité absolue à aucun moment
nous n'avons transigé avec la sûreté
nous avons parfois dû prendre des
décisions difficiles comme de mettre à
la récente réacteurs en plein hiver mais
nous devions le faire et ce principe qui
dit que la sûreté nucléaire est notre
priorité absolue nous l'avons mis en
application
corollaire du point précédent c'est la
relation bien sûr avec l'Autorité de
Sûreté Nucléaire une relation qui doit
être de qualité fondée sur la confiance
le dialogue et une transparence
irréprochable nous nous sommes appliqués
là aussi à respecter ses principes tout
au long de la crise parce que c'est un
élément indispensable au bon
fonctionnement de l'industrie nucléaire
civile
enfin
troisième point concerne notre volonté
constante de partager avec l'ASM de
disposer aussi rapidement que possible
d'un état de situation précis d'où les
115 expertises et tout ce que je viens
de vous décrire je voudrais à nouveau
remercier tous les agents d'EDF et tous
les salariés de nos entreprises
partenaires pour leur mobilisation tout
au long de cette année nous sommes
aujourd'hui en train de sortir peu à peu
de la crise pour apporter au pays
l'électricité dont il a besoin non
seulement pour l'hiver mais aussi pour
les prochaines saisons Mesdames et
Messieurs les parlementaires vous
pourrez toujours compter sur EDF et ses
agents pour assurer cette belle et
grande mission d'intérêt général quel
service public de l'électricité avec
Etienne Duteil directeur du parc
nucléaire Hubert catalet qui est
derrière moi directeur du projet
corrosion sous contrainte nous sommes
bien sûr à votre entière disposition
pour répondre à vos questions merci de
votre attention
je vous remercie pour votre propos nous
avons bien compris que votre priorité
absolue comme vous l'avez dit était la
Sûreté Nucléaire je laisse donc la
parole au président Bernard derosuc de
son analyse sur cette situation et
notamment sur les décisions qui ont pu
être prises par l'autorité de sûreté
nucléaire
merci merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le vice-président Mesdames et
Messieurs les parlementaires tout
d'abord merci de nous accueillir
aujourd'hui pour cette réunion de lopex
consacrée à la corrosion sous contrainte
qui a été découverte sur le parc
nucléaire d'EDF je suis accompagné
d'Olivier gusta directeur général de la
SN et d'un certain nombre de
représentants de la SN qui pourront
également répondre aux questions qui
seront posées par les membres de lopex
alors sans reprendre le propos
introductif de Cédric Lewandowski qui
est très complet je voudrais de manière
générale et de manière liminaire
insister sur quatre points
alors le premier point c'est que tout
d'abord la corrosion sous contrainte et
je dirais pour être plus précis la
fissuration par corrosion sous
contrainte est un sujet sérieux qui a
été traité sérieusement par EDF
alors c'est un sujet sérieux d'abord
parce que
la fissuration par corrosion sous
contrainte comporte de réels enjeux de
sûreté dès lors que elle peut conduire à
une brèche sur un circuit auxiliaire
directement connecté au circuit primaire
sans possibilité de l'isoler comme ça a
été rappelé donc c'est sérieux en
matière de sûreté en cas de brèche
primaire donc s'il y avait une rupture
de ces circuits auxiliaires nous serions
clairement dans une situation
accidentelle
une section une situation accidentelle
avec des dommages en installation et
potentiellement une perte durable du
réacteur éventuellement même avec des
rejets à l'extérieur modérés mais
existants
donc il s'agit absolument pas de
minimiser l'impact d'un tel événement la
situation c'est une situation sérieuse
la fissuration parcourusion sous
contrainte est un sujet sérieux parce
que il est maintenant clairement
générique sur les réacteurs les quatre
réacteurs du pallier N4 et
potentiellement générique sur les 12
réacteurs du palier pinkat comme
l'indiqué Cédric lors de ce qui
et enfin les fissurations de corrosion
sous contrainte qui ont été découvertes
ne sont pas négligeables elles sont
potentiellement évolutives au sein de
l'épaisseur et peuvent atteindre
plusieurs millimètres des valeurs ont
été données je les confirme ça peut
atteindre jusqu'au quart de l'épaisseur
avec peu de marge par rapport à la
taille du défaut critique qui pourrait
entraîner une rupture de la canalisation
en cas de déclenchement de déclenchement
pardon du circuit d'injection de
sécurité donc c'est un sujet sérieux
si la fissuration par corrosion sous
contrainte est un sujet sérieux c'est
aussi un sujet difficile à traiter
il s'agit d'une fissuration inattendue
vu le type de matériaux qui était
utilisé pour fabriquer ses circuits et à
ce stade inédite je le confirme à cet
ampleur sur le parc mondial des
réacteurs à eau sous pression et donc
les exploitants EDF ne disposaient
d'aucun retour d'expérience
internationale pouvant accélérer le
traitement de ce phénomène il s'agit
d'une fissuration difficile à détecter
car se propageant d'une certaine manière
en ligne brisée ce n'est pas une
fissuration de type fatigue thermique en
ligne droite elle se propage en ligne
brisée en suivant les joints du métal et
donc les dispositifs de contrôle non
destructif qui étaient disponibles au
moment de la découverte de cet événement
qu'il était pas adapté à la
caractérisation de ce type de
fissuration ne permettait pas de
connaître exactement la taille de cette
fissuration
et enfin il s'agit d'un sujet difficile
à traiter car il nécessite des
interventions pour le contrôle et la
réparation en milieu dosant proche du
circuit primaire principal ce qui impose
des protections et une durée limitée
d'intervention pour les travailleurs
s'il s'agit d'un sujet sérieux et
difficile c'est aussi un sujet qui a été
traité très sérieusement par EDF je
confirme tout à fait ce qui a été dit
par Cédric Lewandowski à l'instant sur
la mobilisation de la totalité des
équipes d'EDF et des prestataires pour
pouvoir mieux approfondir la
connaissance de la situation et prendre
des mesures de prudence dans
l'incapacité que nous étions au
démarrage de cet événement de
caractériser la taille des fissurations
ces équipes ont travaillé en étroite
relation avec la direction des
équipements sous pression de la SN qui
dispose d'une expertise reconnue sur ces
sujets et avec la direction des
centrales nucléaires de la SN avec
l'appui technique de l'IRSN que je tiens
à remercier
deuxième point
EDF a déployé un plan d'investigation
conséquent très rapidement qui lui a
permis de proposer une stratégie
priorisée de contrôle et de réparation
cette stratégie a été approuvée par la
scène fin juillet elle doit désormais
être mise en œuvre
comme la décrit Cédric levant de ski le
premier semestre 2022 a été consacrée à
la mise en oeuvre d'un plan
d'investigation conséquent proposé par
EDF et je n'y reviendrai pas ce plan
basé sur des découpes et des expertises
ainsi que sur des justifications de
sûreté a permis de dégager une vue plus
complète de l'état du parc et des enjeux
de sûreté ce plan d'investigation était
indispensable pour comprendre le
phénomène
identifier les zones des réacteurs les
plus concernés et définir une stratégie
de contrôle priorisé la SN a estimé que
ce plan d'investigation a été pertinent
comme cela a été indiqué les
investigations menées ont permis
d'identifier la géométrie des
tuyauteries et les contraintes
mécaniques comme étant les principaux
facteurs d'influence de l'apparition des
fissures de corrosion sous contrainte
les soudures réalisées avec de fortes
énergies de soudage et sans harasage
constituent également un facteur
aggravant en ce qui concerne le
développement de ces fissurations sous
contrainte et donc la qualité des
soudures notamment celles qui seront
mises en oeuvre pour réparer les
circuits même si les baux d'opératoires
sont identiques à se utiliser à la
construction initiale doit être
particulièrement soigné pour éviter la
réapparition de le plus possible de ce
type de fissuration
ce plan d'investigation a permis
d'identifier comme cela a été dit les
réacteurs N4 et les réacteurs du 13100
du palier Pinka comme étant les plus
sollicités il y a donc au total 16
réacteurs 4 N4 plus 12 Breen 4 qui sont
prioritaires
7 réacteurs parmi les 16 étaient
couverts par le plan d'investigation de
EDF donc fait l'objet de découpe ou
d'investigation pour pouvoir connaître
l'état de ces de ces circuits et
éventuellement engager des réparations 7
3 sont en cours de contrôle par rapport
à la stratégie qui a été proposée par
EDF et six réacteurs reste encore à
contrôler d'ici mi-2023 au plus tard
c'est l'application de la stratégie
proposée par EDF qui a été validé par
l'ASL une priorisation dans les
opérations de contrôle d'ici mi-2023 sur
les 16 réacteurs qui sont considérés
comme étant les plus sensibles
nous avons estimé que cette stratégie
proposée par EDF était approprié compte
tenu à la fois des connaissances
acquises sur le phénomène et des enjeux
de sûreté qui étaient associés les
contrôles seront réalisés avec un
nouveau procédé non destructif par
ultrason qui pour la première fois
permettra de caractériser la taille des
défauts sans avoir besoin de procéder à
des découpes et donc à des réparations
les premiers résultats de développement
de cette nouvelle méthode de contrôle
sont encourageants mais il reste encore
à consolider et cette technique de
contrôle devra être qualifiée
une attention particulière devra être
portée au soudure qui ont été réparés au
moment de la construction initiale nous
avons constaté au fur et à mesure des
investigations qui ont été menées des
expertises que les soudures qui ont été
réparées intruisent des champs de
contraintes différentes à proximité de
soudure et peuvent être à l'origine de
développement plus rapide de corrosion
sous contrat donc toutes les soudures
qui ont été réparées au moment de la
construction d'origine devront être
contrôlés par la nouvelle technique de
contrôle en fonction des résultats qui
seront obtenus de la caractérisation de
ces contrôles sur les 16 réacteurs avec
toutes les soudures réparées l'ASN
pourra être amenée à demander soit la
remise en état des circuits affectés si
la taille des fissurations est
importante soit d'accepter la remise en
état de manière différée après
justification
troisième point vu le caractère inédit
et les enjeux de sûreté le phénomène de
corrosion sous contrainte suscite un
besoin naturel de transparence
d'information et de partage d'expérience
la présente table ronde en est
d'ailleurs parfaitement l'illustration
pendant toute la période d'investigation
et de dialogue technique avec EDF l'ASN
c'était forcé de garantir cette
information et la transparence du public
ainsi que l'échange d'expérience avec
ses homologues à l'étranger
dès les premiers échanges avec EDF en
janvier 2022 l'ASN a mis en ligne un
dossier spécifique sur la problématique
de corrosion sous contrainte sur son
site internet consultable bien
évidemment partout dans lequel figure à
ce jour l'ensemble de ces courriers de
demande de ces prises de position ainsi
que les notes d'information qui ont été
émises sur le sujet les divisions
territoriales de l'ASM ont participé aux
réunions des commissions locales
d'information qui ont abordé ce sujet
pour leur faire part de l'état des
connaissances et du dialogue que nous
avions avec EDF de la même manière la SN
est intervenue lors des présentations
qui ont été faites par EDF lors des
réunions du haut-commité sur la
transparence et la sécurité nucléaire et
participera au prochain webinaire
organisé par l'ampli et les clients sur
ce sujet les groupes permanents
d'experts placés auprès de la SN ont été
tenus informés et ce sont prononcés sur
les avis émis par des avis émis pardon
de la SN sur la stratégie proposée par
EDF et les moyens de contrôle qui ont
été développés nous avons réalisé 38
inspections sur le sujet depuis le début
de cette affaire ou poursuivons de très
près les opérations les chantiers qui
sont réalisés par les prestataires et
les lettres de suite de ces inspections
sont toutes disponibles également sur le
site internet de la SN nous avons mené
plusieurs actions de partage de
connaissances et d'échanges avec les
autres régulateurs internationaux soit
dans le cadre des instances européennes
Lens règle waynera des instances
internationales comme l'INRA et dans le
cas des réunions bilatérales que nous
avons avec nos homologues à l'étranger
et je dois dire qu'il y a une forte
demande de connaissance d'information de
la part nos homologues qui s'agit de nos
homologues européens de nos homologues
nord-américains asiatiques et même
l'Afrique du Sud qui est équipée de
réacteurs de conception
proche d'un concept français
donc ce sujet suscite un fort intérêt et
de nombreux régulateurs ont d'ores et
déjà demandé à leurs exploitants de
réaliser des contrôles sur leurs propres
installations
enfin je terminerai par un quatrième
point qui est concerne les enseignements
que nous pouvons tirer à ce stade de cet
événement j'envoie trois principaux tout
d'abord au vu des découvertes faites je
pense qu'il faut d'abord en tirer un
enseignement de prudence la SN considère
que les connaissances sur le phénomène
de corrosion sous contrainte sont encore
évolutives et que le programme de
contrôle devra être adapté si les
contrôles ou les analyses mettez en
évidence des éléments nouveaux
le premier résultat de contrôle réalisé
par la technique de NDA améliorée montre
que des tailles de fissuration non
rencontrées dans la phase
d'investigation avec des coupes pourrait
être détecté et de même il faut rester
prudent sur les capacités industrielles
disponibles qui mobilise des segments
industriels déjà en tension mais
contrôleurs non destructifs les
tuyauteurs les soudeurs et il convient
renforcer davantage
ses capacités industrielles pour pouvoir
faire face bien sûr à l'ampleur des
opérations de contrôle et de travaux qui
sont encore devant nous
le second enseignement et que dans une
démarche de défense en profondeur la
capacité des exploitants à aller voir
les choses auxquelles on ne s'attend pas
nécessairement doit être conforté doit
être entretenu c'est l'objet certes des
plans de maintenance préventive des
exploitants qui devront être complétés
au vu du retour d'expérience de cet
événement mais aussi de l'examen de
conformité détaillé que nous demandons
aux exploitants de réaliser lors des
visites décennales comme l'indiqué
Cédric Le mandusky c'est d'ailleurs à
l'occasion d'une visite décennale que le
phénomène a été découvert allez voir les
parties de l'installation que l'on ne
voit pas facilement en exploitation
normale par exemple des réseaux enterrés
des câbles électriques d'autres parties
de l'installation vérifiez que les a
priori sur la tenue des équipements sont
bien justifiés et utiliser les nouvelles
techniques de contrôle non plus
performante reste une préoccupation des
exploitantes dans les industriars
risques de manière générale c'est
valable dans le nucléaire comme dans les
autres secteurs d'industrie à risque la
chimie le pétrole lovecchio voire même
pour les grands ouvrages de génie civil
donc c'est on est face à un phénomène
qui est un phénomène industriel qui est
un phénomène normal naturel de
progression je dirais dans la
connaissance de la tenue des
installations donc il faut l'entretenir
parce que il est tout à fait
indispensable on le voit bien avec la
découverte de phénomènes qui étaient
inattendus et enfin le dernier
enseignement que je tire à ce stade
c'est la réaffirmation du besoin maintes
fois exprimé par la SN de disposer de
marge pour la sûreté
en 2013 la SN avait formulé un avis dans
ce sens dans le cadre du débat sur la
politique énergétique à l'époque dans
cet avis la SN soulignait l'importance
de disposer de marches suffisantes dans
le système électrique pour pouvoir faire
face à la nécessité de suspendre
simultanément pour des raisons de sûreté
le fonctionnement de plusieurs réacteurs
ce besoin a été réaffirmé à plusieurs
reprises notamment dans les rapports
annuels de la SF sur l'état de la sûreté
et lors des présentations de ces
rapports à l'OPEX notamment le rapport
de 2018 et le rapporte 2021 la situation
actuelle illustre la nécessité
impérative de restaurer des marges pour
la sûreté dans le futur mix énergétique
et dans les décisions qui seront prises
en termes de dimensionnement des
capacités de production électrique
quelle qu'elle soit pour dans le cadre
de du mix énergétique à l'horizon 2050
voilà monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président ce que je mesdam et Messieurs
les parlementaires ce que je vous
souhaitez dire en propos liminaire
je vous remercie j'essaie de la parole à
Jean-Christophe Niel directeur général
de l'IRSN qui va pouvoir également
compléter le propos et l'appui sur le
volet technique de cette corrosion sous
contrainte vous avez la parole monsieur
le Président Mesdames et Messieurs
parlementaires donc c'est toujours un
honneur de d'avoir la possibilité de
d'aborder des sujets dont nous avons la
responsabilité
oui
c'est plus c'est plus pratique quoi donc
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les parlementaires c'est
toujours un honneur de pouvoir vous
présenter
les sujets sur lequel nous sommes
investi surtout quand ils ont
l'importance qui a été rappelée par
Cédric Lewandowski et Bernard de Rosu
donc c'est un travail sur lequel on
intervenons sous forme notamment d'avis
à l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire sur
l'occasion d'y revenir donc je balaye un
certain nombre de sujets il y aura
quelques illustrations pour appuyer mes
propos donc le premier point c'est le
retour d'expérience
et donc c'est c'est revenir sur sur
l'ampleur de séparer de corrosion en
sous contrainte dans le champ des
réacteurs
nucléaires notamment des réacteurs à eau
pressuriser effectivement il y a peu de
cas qui ont été rencontrés au niveau
international c'est afin qu'il y ait
plus fréquent sur les réacteur au
bouillante notamment parce que justement
il y a des présences de vapeur et et
dont je l'occasion d'y revenir alors il
y a quelques cas qui ont été recensés il
y a un travail de l'EPRI qui est les
prix qui est l'association des
électriciens américains qui a conduit ce
travail qui était arrivé à une valeur de
près 150 c'est le diagramme qui est à
droite là
en fait ce nombre est faible au regard
de l'ensemble des soudures
potentiellement concernés du nombre de
réacteurs et du nombre de composants
même si effectivement le taux de sondage
et variable et plutôt faible entre 10 et
25%
ce qu'on peut dire c'est que dans la
plus grande partie de ces cas c'est ce
qu'on voit là aussi sur le diagramme
c'est des situations dites en milieu
occlus c'est à dire c'est c'est un
morceau de tuyauterie dans lequel le
fluide circule pas ou peu
voilà ce qu'on appelle aussi un bras
mort il y a aussi un certain nombre de
cas qu'on appelle nonominaux ces terres
ou par exemple il va y avoir des écarts
sur les spécifications chimiques par
rapport aux spécialisations chimiques
comme ça a été dit la croissance
contrainte c'est une qualité d'un
matériau c'est une contrainte mécanique
et c'est une dimension chimique voilà
donc ce qu'on peut dire clairement c'est
que le retour d'expérience sur cette
situation détectée il y a un nom
maintenant est atypique en terme détendu
sur l'ensemble des réacteurs à eau sous
pression
je veux bien qu'on passe au slide
suivant alors sur l'origine
nous partageons la position d'EDF qu'il
s'agit d'un phénom de
stratification thermique
stratifia qui sont thermiques ça veut
dire que c'est de l'étalement de la
température dans un même tuyau le front
la température l'eau froide étant en bas
l'eau chaude en haut sur le même tuyau
vous allez avoir une partie froide ou le
métal va tendance à se contracter une
partie chaude d'avoir atteint assez
tendre et donc une contrainte qu'il ne
faut pas confondre il y a un certain
nombre de publications qui circulent en
ce moment sur le jeu qui ne trouvera
confondre avec la fatigue thermique qui
est une alternance de chaud et de froid
qui a été évoquée thermique vous pouvez
avoir un exemple simple c'est le
trombone que vous prenez vous tordez
comme ça bien chaud puis à mon cas ça
c'est de la fatigue thermique là c'est
autre chose c'est la stratification
thermique c'est à dire que liée
justement à cette eau qui est stable
dans le bras mort bah l'eau froide va
être en bas l'eau chaude en haut et donc
engendre des contraintes alors il y a un
facteur sur lequel
nous avons conscient qui était important
que DF approfondisse le sujet c'est la
présence d'hydrogène dans le circuit
primaire de d'oxygène pardon dans le
circuit primaire qui est un facteur de
risque de corrosion sous contrainte pour
le type d'acide dont il est question on
appelle ça des astiers inoxydables
oxénétiques
austenity et en fait c'est un
oxygène qui va être
introduit dans le circuit primaire à
l'occasion d'injection de haut il y a ce
qu'on appelle des bâches c'est des
réservoirs qui pour des raisons de
fonctionnement du réacteur vont un
injecter notamment de l'eau ou du bord
le bord est un composant qui va
permettre de ralentir la réaction
nucléaire c'est notamment un composant
qui existe en fonctionnement normal mais
aussi en situation
accidentelle et donc il y a un certain
nombre de de situation où le ou le ou
l'eau qui est qui est qui est injecté
n'a pas été désaré des ARS ça veut dire
inert
et notamment c'est le cas pour les
réacteurs de 131450 mégawatts un 1300 et
N4 ou
depuis l'origine la bâche
est en contact d'oxygène de l'air et
donc peu en entraîner dans le circuit
primaire au début les réacteurs de 900
MW a été inerté à part de l'azote et
depuis quelques années son désertés
notamment suite à un accident du travail
d'anxie à cause de l'azote ça nous
semble être un facteur à regarder même
si aujourd'hui les mesures faites en
broncho dans sortie du réacteur montre
un taux d'oxygène qui est plutôt faible
il nous semble qu'il faut que ds
s'intéresse à l'objet en amont du du
coeur du réacteur donc l'amont du cœur
du réacteur c'est l'eau qui provient
directement des guides dash et il nous
semble que c'est un jeu qui doit être
expertise d'ailleurs c'est une demande
que l'IRSN a reprises dans les suites
des travaux du groupe permanent à qui
nous avions proposé cette cette démarche
donc c'est un facteur de notre point de
vue à étudier comme facteur de corrosion
sous contrainte ça a un impact sur la
cinétique de propagation des fissures et
notamment si c'est un paramètre qu'on
que d'être soit utilisé dans le cadre de
justification auquel je reviendrai dans
quelques instants le point suivant alors
les enjeux de sûreté
donc le circuit d'injection de sécurité
ça a bien été rappelé tout à l'heure
c'est un circuit qui est essentiel à la
prévention de la fusion du cœur en cas
d'accident c'est un circuit qui est
connecté sur le circuit primaire donc
qui est auxiliaire au circuit primaire
et entre la connexion sur primaire et le
premier isolement il y a il y a un bras
il y a un morceau de tuyauterie qui en
cas de fissuration engendre une de fait
une fuite sur le circuit primaire parce
qu'il n'est pas possible de l'isoler
donc c'est pour ça que c'est parti en
sensible en fait dans les réacteurs il y
a quatre lignes d'injection dans les
branches froides du du circuit la
démonstration de sûreté
faite par l'opérateur dans le cadre de
la mise en scène de ces de son
installation demande l'étude de la
rupture d'une ligne donc c'est ce qui
est écrit là donc une brèche couverte
une brèche c'est couvert par
démonstration de sûreté de brèche ce
n'est pas couvert néanmoins EDF a
procédé à des calculs de deux brèches
simultanées sur deux lignes
arrive à la conclusion qui a pas de
fusion du cœur sur les 1300 mm le
combustible va rester intègre bien que
ce soit comme la rappeler Bernard
derosugue une situation accidentelle il
faut pas se méprendre sur le sujet
l'IRSN a fait ses propres calculs et
partage les conclusions tirées par EDF
je reviens maintenant au système de
contrôle alors comme ça a été rappelé il
y avait pas de système de moyens de
contrôle adapté à la corrosion sous
contrainte le les systèmes ultrasoniques
utilisés
étaient destinée à détecter de la
fatigue thermique des contrôles
ultrasonor c'est comme des échographies
le reflet le rebond d'un d'un du nom de
sonore et ça l'analyse la corrosion sous
contrainte à un parcours qui est très
déstructuré très haché ce qui ne
favorise pas le renvoi d'un faisceau à
peu près homogène donc ça rend la
lecture difficile c'est pour ça que les
moyens de contrôle ne sont pas adaptés
dans un premier temps EDF a souhaité on
a fait un avis sur le sujet renforcé la
sensibilité du dispositif existant en
fait que ça a surtout fait c'est que ça
a fait apparaître des tas d'indications
qui ne correspondaient pas à des réels
défauts tout simplement parce que le
dispositif n'est pas adapté donc le
moyen de contrôle donc on peut
effectivement constater le sujet
compliqué que un travail très important
a été fait
le dispositif de contrôle permet
d'obtenir un certain nombre de choses le
travail n'est pas finalisé donc ce que
je peux dire là c'est dans le tableau là
qu'on voit bien qu'on voit c'est qu'il y
a des points positifs des points
d'amélioration avant de disputer d'un
système de contrôle qu'on est en
performant donc le point positif c'est
que ça permet de détecter des défauts de
CSC de caractériser leur hauteur sur la
base de de décès de test
ce système de contrôle permet
d'enregistrer les images du traceur
pourquoi c'est utile parce que ça permet
de ne pas connecter une interprétation
sur site ça peut permettre d'avoir
recours à des experts plus pertinents
c'est comme les échographies les gens
plus ou moins compétents sur le sujet et
puis il a pu être constaté que pour les
défauts qui ont été utilisés pour
calibrer la méthode il y a une bonne
reproduction c'est-à-dire qu'on est
capable des f est capable de trouver la
taille effectivement du défaut on a
simulé on n'a pas on n'a pas les les
mesures les mesures réelles mais on voit
simuler ce que ça faisait la détection
d'un défaut à gauche genre vraiment les
sujets sur lequel il faut progresser
d'abord faire une vraie qualification de
la qualification ça obéit un certain
nombre d'étapes et de passage obligé
c'est un processus
formaté on va dire
le dispositif présente un certain nombre
de limites à ce stade dans sa mise en
oeuvre notamment par rapport à des
géométries complexes
et puis enfin
pour l'instant le les grands défauts et
et des fois proximités de soudure n'ont
pas été utilisés pour Kaiser le pour
qualifier le procès j'ai mis une image
en bas donc à droite vous avez une
soudure réparée vous voyez ça fait une
espèce de de
double boss donc ça c'est une soudure
réparée et on voit bien que à gauche
c'est l'appareil en jaune c'est
l'appareil en rouge c'est le faisceau on
voit bien que le faisceau il peut taper
la partie gauche de la fissure à ne pas
voir la partie droite voilà donc il y a
des configurations sur lequel il faut il
faut progresser mais comme ça a été dit
par les intervenants précédents le
dispositif n'est pas parfait il faut
aller au bout du processus le stade
suivant c'est une illustration de ce que
ça veut dire l'étude de la nocivité des
des des défauts
avec la question de peut-on laisser un
défaut en l'état et le réacteur utile
pour fonctionner un certain temps alors
de manière générale en sûreté il vaut
mieux réparer justifier mais il arrive
que dans certaines situations il soit
utile de justifier la démarche à ce
moment-là est la suivante vous avez un
il faut des fier ce qu'on appelle un
défaut critique un défaut critique c'est
quoi s'il y a un défaut
d'une certaine hauteur et au dessus de
la hauteur de ce défaut critique
l'intégrité de la tuyauterie n'est plus
garantie donc dit autrement il faut
pouvoir apporter la garantie qu'on qu'on
que le système reste sous le défaut
critique les démarches suivies et la
suivante c'est il y a une mesure qui est
faite ensuite est intégré l'incertitude
de la mesure et puis point important
c'est il faut intégrer aussi la
propagation de la fissure évaluée par
les moyens qui qui vont bien pendant le
fonctionnement qui est anticipé tout ça
doit évidemment arriver à une marche
positive c'est pour ça que tout à
l'heure j'ai insisté sur le rôle de
l'hydrogène sur la vitesse de
restauration de l'oxygène
voilà et mon dernier Slide est
déconclusions donc une compréhension du
phénomène qui reste à compléter beaucoup
de choses a été faites ça a été dit mais
on n'est pas au bout de la démarche
des actions de R&D ont été citées par
Cédric Lewandowski par exemple
le sujet le plus important de notre
point de vue c'est comme une filer le
procès de contrôle qui d'ailleurs devra
à terme est intégré dans les programmes
de maintenance
d'EDF et donc il faudra procéder d'une
part la qualification de ce procédé pour
qu'il soit complètement pertinent et
réaliser les contrôles sur l'ensemble
des réacteurs en priorisant comme de là
aussi ça a été dit les réacteurs au
pprmecat enfin il y a un travail à faire
sur la la la
la la question de l'oxygène dans l'eau
d'appoint du circuit primaire c'est à
mieux comprendre mieux instrumenter les
circuits et le cas échéant fait évoluer
les modes de gestion pour réduire ce
taux d'hydrogène alors depuis
depuis un an il y a Hassen et très
mobilisée sur ce sujet on a une dizaine
de personnes qui travaillent sur ce
sujet et en tant qu'humé cela faire les
clients de 5 équiloles en temps plein
donc c'est un travail important j'ai eu
l'occasion d'exprimer à plusieurs
plusieurs reprises devant la
représentation nationale que
l'IRSN et régulièrement à régulièrement
et c'est normal sa mission à mobiliser
des moyens sur des sujets inattendus
c'était pas sans effet sur sa capacité
de fonction là c'est un très bel exemple
puis évidemment ce sujet il y a un an
était inattendu quelques avis sur lequel
les avis d'ailleurs sur lequel nous
avons positionné pour la SN sur
l'analyse des du procès d'examen
ultrasonor optimisé c'est ce que j'ai
évoqué tout à l'heure c'est dans une
première étape EDF avait souhaité
renforcer la sensibilité donc ce sujet
n'est plus d'actualité puisque EDF a
développé un nouveau système qui
s'appelle système d'ultrasonore amélioré
on a évoqué on a fait un avis sur
l'analyse de de risques de risque brutal
et donc là c'est la question de l'étude
de sûreté avec deux brèches simultanées
le troisième avis c'est EDF a pris des
mesures compensatoires qui ont pas été
évoqué me semble aussi à ce stade en
terme de fonctionnement pour essayer
d'anticiper
une brèche à venir notamment par le
suivi de fuite du circuit primaire donc
il va renforcement des dispositions nous
avons été rétention sur le fait qu'un
outil
utile pour détecter des fuites c'est les
dispositifs incendies qui détectent de
la vapeur à peu près 50% des circuits
Rice et RR circuit à l'arrêt et
refroidissement à l'arrêt injection de
sécurité relation à l'arrêt passe dans
des locaux il y a des détections et des
sons d'incendie qui ont la
caractéristique de se déclencher en cas
de vapeur d'eau donc c'est une
recommandation importante de notre de
notre
de notre
avis il y a la vie sur le sur l'oxygène
qui est la vie de cet angle le dernier
avis qui est tous ses amis sont plus sur
le qui vient d'être mis à
l'ASN sur la possibilité de de
fonctionner avec une fissure on conclut
dans cet avis à son entrée dans le
détail sur le fait qu'il faut renforcer
la démonstration de cette capacité voilà
ce que je voulais dire à ce stade je
suis accompagné par Karine hervion qui
est directrice générale de adjoine de
l'irsen que vous voyez beaucoup à la
télé sur zapouria et qui pourra répondre
aux questions sur le sujet en ma
compagnie merci
bien je vous remercie pour cette
présentation
claire et synthétique nous savons que
l'enjeu énergétique nucléaire n'est pas
simplement un sujet technique c'est
aussi un sujet à dimension politique
notamment cette période de crise
énergétique c'est pourquoi nous avons le
plaisir également d'accueillir des
représentants de la société civile
nous allons d'abord entendre un
interlocuteur de longue date de l'office
en la personne d'Yves Marignac chef du
pôle d'expertise nucléaire et fossiles
de l'Institut negawatts je vous laisse
la parole
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les parlementaires je suis
très heureux de pouvoir apporter un
éclairage complémentaire au compte-rendu
que viennent de nous apporter les
acteurs institutionnels et je voudrais
commencer par saluer le sérieux
l'étendue la rapidité du travail
d'analyse technique qui a été mené et
résumé ici
dont nous avons notamment pu prendre
connaissance en groupe permanent
d'experts même si je regrette s'agissant
d'un sujet spécifiquement équipement
sous pression nucléaire qu'on y dispose
pas pour des raisons institutionnelles
du même niveau de mise en critique par
l'IRSN que sur d'autres dossiers de
sûreté pour autant je voudrais insister
sur quelques enseignements à tirer de
cette situation en commençant par
rappeler que au vu des résultats date
qui pointe l'apparition et le
développement rapide du phénomène
jusqu'à atteindre une zone de
compression qui a arrêté la propagation
de ces fissures et bien une dizaine de
réacteurs ont fonctionné depuis 15 à 20
ans avec des fissures non détectées sur
un circuit d'importance essentiel pour
la sûreté ce qui évidemment n'est pas
rien alors certes c'est fissures
semblent s'être arrêté qui a une
profondeur qui permet en tout cas de
tenter de justifier leur nom nocivité et
aucune situation d'accident n'a
nécessité d'éprouver leur robustesse en
situation critique mais on aurait aussi
bien pu être confronté à cela et
ce constat je pense doit nous conduire à
beaucoup de modestie concernant l'état
réel des réacteurs par rapport aux
hypothèses de sûreté le fameux sujet de
la de la conformité en l'occurrence un
point qui me semble important c'est que
si l'instruction technique c'est à juste
titre concentré sur la caractérisation
du phénomène sa compréhension et la
stratégie de gestion qui en découle on a
peu discuté en fait de la manière dont
ce risque pas été correctement ou non
pris en compte à la conception
si on en croit les explications
techniques sur le fait que le phénomène
de stratification lié à l'allongement
des lignes soit le facteur déclenchant
on peut en déduire que si le risque de
corrosion sous contrainte était bien
identifié des dès l'origine il n'a pas
été maîtrisé à deux niveaux clés de la
défense en profondeur la conception et
la surveillance en particulier
il semble que si l'ensemble des
paramètres a apporté une qualification
correcte sur les réacteurs 900 MW de
Westinghouse dont le modèle a été
importé en France voilà l'impact de
l'allongement de ces lignes n'a pas été
anticipé lors du passage au palier 1300
puis au Palli and 4 au passage on peut
s'interroger sur la manière dont ce
point a été traité dans l'augmentation
des puissances de réacteurs conçus au
fil du temps par Westinghouse sur la
même base qui ne semble pas affecter par
le même problème au delà de ce constat
ce qui m'inquiète dans cette situation
c'est qu'elle nous dit des choses de la
faible capacité prédictive des
propriétés mécaniques des équipements
sous pression nucléaire hors de leur
domaine qualifié
dans le domaine qualifié tout va bien et
on dispose d'une grande capacité de
caractérisation destructive des
propriétés de ces équipements qui donc
permet de qualifier un domaine de
dimensionnement mais on constate que la
multiplication des facteurs en jeu les
nuances d'acier les écarts de
composition les modes de soudage les
différentes contraintes auxquelles ces
équipements sont soumis et la complexité
des relations entre ces différents
facteurs rend visiblement difficile de
projeter les conséquences sur les
propriétés attendues de différents
écarts par rapport au domaine qualifié
on l'avait vu ça a été rappelé je crois
par Monsieur le vice-président tout à
l'heure sur la cuve de l'EPR ou un
nombre décès aussi important que pour la
qualification de l'ensemble des cuves du
parc actuel a été nécessaire pour
caractériser les propriétés du couvercle
et du fond de cuve ségrégé on l'a vu
aussi sur le dossier du générateur de
vapeur de Fessenheim ou une pièce qui
avait été fabriquée de façon
explicitement non conforme aux procédé
initial à fait l'objet après dépôt d'un
dossier de justification par EDF d'une
conclusion positive et je me souviens
encore que en groupe permanent de
nombreux experts ce sont déclarés
surpris par le comportement étonnamment
bon de cette pièce en d'autres termes il
n'était pas en mesure de prédire
correctement l'impact des écarts
constatés
cela veut dire que du point de vue de la
sûreté on est exposé
au risque que des écarts même minimes
dans les conditions de fabrication ou
d'exploitation de ces équipements sous
pression nucléaire conduisent à des
écarts potentiellement important de leur
comportement par rapport aux propriétés
attendues et ce point m'amène à deux
préoccupations
la première s'agissant du parc actuel
c'est que il faut s'interroger sur tous
les écarts de conformité repérées voire
non repérés mais pour ceux qui sont
repérés je pense en particulier au
dossier de fabrication de Creusot forge
dont
une grande partie a fait l'objet des cas
et sur la manière dont les incertitudes
générés par ces écarts sont croisés dans
les démonstrations de sûreté avec
différents enjeux ces démonstrations
postulant au titre de la conformité
que les équipements
réagissent comme il est prévu mais c'est
études à mon sens ne sont pas enfin
c'est cette hypothèse d'écart n'est pas
suffisamment croisée lorsque il s'agit
des analyses de conformité des analyses
de vieillissement ou de celles sur la
tenue à des situations extrêmes
[Musique]
lors de la conception de le père de
Flamanville avec le succès que l'on sait
on a pu observer les problèmes des
soudures du circuit secondaire principal
ou des piquage de circuit auxiliaire sur
sur le circuit primaire et EDF souhaite
à nouveau appliquer de façon expansive
ce principe d'exclusion de rupture à la
conception de l'EPR je pense que les
difficultés
constatées dans dans ce dossier doivent
amener à beaucoup plus de prudence sur
ce point le deuxième volet que je
souhaite développer un peu plus
rapidement c'est la question des
problèmes d'arbitrage entre sûreté et
sécurité on le sait depuis longtemps la
forte dépendance du système électrique
français à un parc nucléaire standardisé
constitue sans négliger l'avantage que
constitue cette standardisation du point
de vue de la sûreté une véritable
fragilité du point de vue de la sécurité
électrique le président de la SN de
l'époque et Monsieur de rosuk l'a
rappelé avait dès 2013 souligné dans le
débat déjà sur la transition énergétique
que le système électrique ne disposait
pas des marges nécessaires pour faire
face à l'indisponibilité pour une raison
de sûreté générique d'une dizaine de
réacteurs on sait qu'on a pas fait grand
chose depuis entre le retard sur les
renouvelables la France est le seul pays
à avoir raté son objectif européen en
2020 la faiblesse des actions de
maîtrise de la demande et le frein à la
fermeture des réacteurs pour diversifier
et réduire cette dépendance et cet hiver
nous y sommes précisément au type de
situation que décrivait pierre Franck
chevet
cette situation elle nous expose en fait
mécaniquement à un arbitrage par nature
malsain entre sécurité électrique et
sûreté nucléaire qui se double dans le
contexte de crise énergétique que nous
connaissons d'une pression induite par
l'envolée des prix de marché que les
perspectives données par EDF avec une
prévision d'appel 50% de facteurs de
charge du pack nucléaire pour
le contrôle priorisant certains
réacteurs pour mieux retarder l'examen
des autres et puis une fois que la SN a
accepté cet état allemand EDF appelé
pour une mise en œuvre rapide des
réparations des portions de circuit
découpé avant même que l'instruction
technique est permis de caractériser
avec suffisamment d'assurance les
facteurs en jeu pour
s'assurer de la non reproduction de ce
problème
appelé par le gouvernement à produire
des signaux susceptibles je cite de
refroidir les marchés EDF a pris des
engagements très volontariste sur le
redémarrage des réacteurs pour s'en
convaincre on peut observer que RTE dans
son analyse prévisionnelle sur le
passage de l'hiver 2022 2023 prévoit sur
la période de décembre à janvier en
hypothèse haute une disponibilité
moyenne du parc environ 10 GW inférieur
aux engagements pris par EDF et
globalement cette situation conduit
aujourd'hui à accélérer les opérations
en faisant appel ça a été dit également
à des soudeurs américains et en
relâchant les marges de prudence
habituellement appliquées vis-à-vis des
limites réglementaires de
radioprotection des travailleurs on
arrive maintenant avec le cas de 4 noms
1 qui a été mentionné rapidement par
l'IRSN à la fin de sa son intervention à
une nouvelle étape ou EDF cherche à
justifier plutôt qu'une découpe et
réparation immédiate sur une voire deux
fissures suspectés si j'ai bien compris
le report de ces opérations à un nouvel
arrêt programmé après l'hiver une telle
stratégie si elle devait être validée
par une décision à venir de l'ASN ne
reposerait clairement pas sur un
raisonnement ne faisant intervenir que
la sûreté mais sur une forme de
dérogation motivée par les enjeux de
sécurité électrique et cette dérive
globalement me semble dangereuse elle
appelle en conclusion à se poser la
question des options pour rendre le
système électrique moins dépendant à la
disponibilité activité à tout prix du
parking nucléaire ça tombe bien c'est en
partie l'objet du débat public sur les
nouveaux EPS qui s'ouvrent aujourd'hui
et de la concertation ouverte par le
gouvernement sur l'avenir du système
énergétique elle appelle également et
c'est une préoccupation fortement
exprimée par le groupe permanent à
l'élaboration par EDF d'une stratégie
plus pérenne de traitement de cette
situation que la méthode de détection
réparation mise en oeuvre dans une
vision de court terme pour l'instant et
puis je finirai par évoquer la question
de la transparence puisque ce point a
été mentionné à plusieurs reprises je
voudrais simplement rappeler ici que
celle-ci ne s'arrête pas à mettre à la
disposition du public l'information
synthétique que l'exploitant ou
l'Autorité estime nécessaire mais elle
doit permettre l'accès du public à toute
l'information non légitimement couverte
par les différents secrets on en reste à
mon sens pour l'instant très loin dans
ce dossier je vous remercie
bien je vous remercie je scène de la
parole à Jean-Claude delalomonde
président de l'Association nationale des
comités commissions locales
d'informations pour un propos assez
court si possible ce qui nous permettra
ensuite de poser des questions
aux collègues merci monsieur le
Président mais vous me permettrez de
vous remercier moi aussi à mon tour
l'invitation que vous avez formulé
vis-à-vis de l'ampli de participer à
cette audition de ce fait je ne doute
pas que chaque personne ici autour de la
table c'est ce que nous sommes vous
permettrait en quelques mots de le
rappeler néanmoins ça me semble
important l'ankli c'est la Fédération
des 35 clients les comités et les
commissions locales d'informations qui
existent et qui se trouve implanté
auprès des installations nucléaires de
base donc 35 en France c'est 35 livres
groupes 5000 bénévoles et ces 35 lis
sont fédérés depuis la loi TSN de 2006
qui qui nous a institutionné
institutionnalisé en tant que client et
en tant que fédération bien que nous
existions avant mais de façon un peu
informelle même si c'était le premier
ministre Mauroy qui avait par une
circulaire incité des présidents
départements à nous créer nous sommes
donc dans l'église 5000 bénévoles et ses
clients délègue au sein de l'association
que je préside quatre représentants qui
constituent ce qu'on appelle la
gouvernance de notre instance cette
gouvernance est donc constituée à part
égale de 25% d'élus
un parc lit de 25% de représentants de
d'associations de défense de
l'environnement un parcli de 25% de
représentants syndicaux qui exerce dans
les installations nucléaires de base
donc un parking et de 25% un parking de
représentants du monde économique ou
d'experts en matière nucléaire ou des
personnes qualifiées et ce qui nous
rassemble à l'encling c'est dans une
constante unanimité dans une constante
unanimité c'est que nous travaillons
nous réfléchissons pour un sujet qui
nous tient à cœur c'est celui de la
défense de la Sûreté Nucléaire le
maintien voire le développement et
surtout pas la dégradation de la sûreté
nucléaire du modèle français auquel nous
nous croyons même si nous sommes divers
dans notre représentativité et où nous
nous exprimons mais unanimement sur ce
sujet et surtout j'insiste sur un sujet
c'est que nous sommes aussi très
respectueux de la représentation
nationale que vous êtes
même si quelquefois on peut ne pas être
d'accord et il est important que
lorsqu'on n'est pas d'accord on
l'exprime en toute convivialité sans
aucune addictif pour faire avancer les
choses comme le sujet aujourd'hui qui
nous rassemble celui de la corrosion
sous contrainte l'esprit je vais laisser
la parole à mon collaborateur Yves Le
roeul qui est le directeur de l'ampli
pour nous expliquer quelles sont les
constats que nous avons fait sur ce
sujet Quels sont les questions que nous
nous posons et quels sont les attentes
de l'ampli après quoi si vous me
permettez si j'ai quelques temps à la
fin c'est mon expression n'aura pas été
trop longue pour vous exprimer quand
même au niveau de l'ampli les
inquiétudes que l'on a sur les problèmes
du nucléaire en France
merci Jean-Claude mesdames Messieurs les
parlementaires monsieur le Président je
vais essayer rapidement essayer
effectivement de vous dresser nos
inquiétudes nos questionnements et nos
attentes qui vont rejoindre des
préoccupations et des propos déjà tenus
par les autres acteurs du nucléaire
effectivement comme ça a été dit par de
nombreux acteurs c'est un événement
générique alors c'est un mélange
générique malheureusement qui a été qui
tombe mal parce qu'il tombe dans une
période où nous vous le savez nous
sommes en pleine tension sur le marché
de l'énergie mais aussi en pleine
tension de recherche d'indépendance
énergétiques et de préoccupations de nos
citoyens vis-à-vis de l'alimentation
électrique de leurs habitations donc
évidemment c'est un événement générique
comme ça a été dit aussi qui avait déjà
été alerté par l'Autorité de sûreté
indiquant que ça pouvait arriver que si
jamais cette ces événements est générés
arrivés il pouvait impacter plusieurs
réacteurs ça a déjà été le cas dans le
passé c'est le cas aujourd'hui et
effectivement ça crée des contraintes
dans un roman qui n'est pas le plus
propice même si ça a été dit aussi par
de nombreux acteurs c'est un sujet qui a
été extrêmement pris au sérieux par tout
le monde et on souhaite nous l'enclit le
souligner avec un partage de
l'information et un souhait de
transparence des informations très
ouvertes de tout le monde
probablement un retour d'expérience des
événements passés qui font
qu'aujourd'hui l'ensemble des acteurs du
nucléaire dont nous considérons faire
partie en tant que quatrième pilier et
bien partage dans l'information depuis
de nombreuses années on a créé on a
réussi ensemble dans nos indépendances
respectives mais aussi dans une
confiance réciproque à développer cette
transparence et ce partage de
l'information et sur ce sujet donc de la
corrosion sous contrainte il y a eu
effectivement de nombreuses
présentations dans les clics et même
dans des commissions locales où le sujet
de la corrosion sous contrainte n'est
pas concernée je prends Gravelines par
exemple qui n'est pas concerné et sur
lequel il y a eu un besoin une demande
en tout cas des citoyens et des acteurs
locaux d'expliquer ce processus j'étais
moi-même dans des réunions publiques de
Golfech et de Tricastin donc à Valence
il y a quelques mois et dans le public
il y avait plus d'une centaine de
personnes dans ces deux réunions
publiques dans ce public il y a eu des
questions sur la corrosion sous
contrainte alors sur le volet sur T mais
sur le volet redémarrage sur le volet
indépendantes électriques sur le volet
est-ce qu'on va pas trop vite est-ce que
tout va démarrer correctement les
questions qu'on se pose aujourd'hui les
citoyens se posent et se posent et
vivement légitimement et juste vous
informer aussi juste avant excusez-moi
vous informer qu'effectivement dans ce
partage de l'information cette volonté
de transparence et ben on a décidé sous
l'impulsion du Haut comité et de sa
présidente madame Noiville et sous
l'impulsion du président de l'ampli
Jean-Claude de La Londe et avec tous les
partenaires donc l'exploitant la
autorité de sûreté et l'Institut de
radioprotection et de sûreté nucléaire
de faire un webinaire toute la journée
le 10 novembre à l'intention de tous les
membres déclics mais élargi aussi à
d'autres à des citoyens s'ils le
souhaitent un webinaire toute la journée
donc ouvert globalement au public pour
rappeler ce qui a été dit ici la
chronologie les explications les
expertises où on en est aujourd'hui mais
aussi les perspectives sur l'avenir donc
un une grande journée dédiée à ce
phénomène de corrosion sous contrainte
et qui monte parce que c'est la première
fois je crois qu'on arrive à monter un
webinaire aussi conséquent avec tout le
monde la volonté de transparence et de
partage de l'information sur sur ce
sujet sur le slide suivant je vais y
venir à nos questionnements alors qui
qui rejoignent des questionsnements que
vous avez qui ont été abordés évidemment
aujourd'hui qui a celui de pourquoi
est-ce qu'on le découvre aujourd'hui ça
a été dit effectivement par Monsieur
Longuet le premier vice-président
pourquoi aujourd'hui pourquoi est-ce
qu'on l'a pas découvert avant est-ce que
ça veut dire que les tests qui ont été
faits lors de la vd2 de si vaut 1 si je
me trompe pas ont été plus importants
que prévu et donc on a découvert à ce
moment-là ce phénomène mais pourquoi
est-ce qu'on l'a pas découvert avant et
surtout ce qui nous inquiète le plus
c'est est-ce que finalement le fait de
ne pas évidemment faire tout ou pas
suffisamment ou pas on passe pas à côté
d'autres phénomènes on a là vous ça a
été dit c'est inattendu c'est imprévu
c'est inédit est-ce qu'il y a pas
d'autres inattendu d'autres imprévus qui
existent dans le fonctionnement des
installations nucléaires et à côté
desquels on passerait parce que on ne
fait pas l'analyse pas le test ou pas le
la bonne méthode ou autre pour l'idée
n'est pas de jeter la pierre sur qui que
ce soit mais plutôt de se poser cette
question de l'inattendu et de l'inédit
est-ce qu'il ça ne va pas se renouveler
et puis du coup ça nous interroge sur la
nécessité de maintenance préventive sur
d'autres circuits et peut-être de
manière plus précoce pour ne pas
attendre d'arriver sur cette inattendue
et cette inédit pour se dire qu'on a
qu'on a besoin de faire d'autres
maintenance et d'autres contrôles et
puis ça a été dit aussi on voit bien
qu'il y a un besoin là de compétences
qu'on a peut-être pu on a parlé de
soudeur italien moi j'ai lu dans la
presse de soudeur américain on a parlé
d'une école de soudure créée par par EDF
il y a beaucoup d'informations qui
circulent un peu partout évidemment que
les citoyens lisent et que les citoyens
s'interrogent et qui nous interrogent
sur les compétences d'être obligé
d'aller chercher un certain nombre
d'acteurs à l'étranger alors que nous
sommes un pays nuclé depuis de
nombreuses années donc effectivement il
y a des questionnements sur les remèdes
et les compétences dont on a besoin
aujourd'hui mais dont on a besoin demain
on va parler de la politique énergétique
avec les débats qui vont commencer ce
soir on voit bien qu'il y a des projets
d'EPR dont celui déjà de panique dans
quelques années donc c'est compétences
on en a besoin on est dans une pyramide
des âges je pense où il y a un transfert
de compétences qui se fait on sait que
EDF et nous la présenter a pris en
compte depuis de nombreuses années ce
transfert des compétences et cette
pyramide des âges qui conduit à la au
départ à la retraite de nombreux de ces
personnels néanmoins est suffisant à ton
pas besoin de de plus de formation et de
compétences compte tenues et on voit là
la difficulté à avoir des gens
compétents pour aider aux réparations
notamment qui ont été qui ont été
nécessaires et juste signalé que donc
sur ce sujet qui est plutôt du facteur
organisationnel et humain l'encli
envisage de faire un livre blanc et un
séminaire sur sur l'année de 2023
et enfin sur nos sur nos attentes qu'il
le dernier point on rejoint là aussi des
préoccupations que j'ai entendu que j'ai
entendu ce matin on a évidemment des
tensions sur le marché de l'énergie
évidemment on a un souhait
d'indépendance mais tout ça nous conduit
à se poser des réflexions sur la
prudence je crois que c'est le mot
utilisé par le président de l'Autorité
de Sûreté Nucléaire prudence vis-à-vis
de l'ensemble de des études en tout cas
nous on considère qu'il y a un besoin de
s'assurer que lorsque l'on va redémarrer
un réacteur et c'est ce qu'on l'on
entend dans les clients auprès du grand
public se redémarrage se fasse dans les
meilleures conditions et dans l'optimum
de sûreté en tout cas nécessaire dont le
fonctionnement du réacteur il y a un
autorité il y a
l'IRSN qui émet des avis il y a la SN
qui émet des décisions l'ensemble de ces
éléments doivent être pris réellement en
compte et sérieusement par les décideurs
pour que ce phénomène de sûreté qui a
été jugé comme inédit mais en tout cas
comme sérieux également et comme très
sérieux
ne se reproduisent pas déjà mais aussi
surtout qu'il soit qu'il ne conduise pas
des redémarrages précipités ce que l'on
peut craindre évidemment je pense
légitimement contenu du contexte actuel
sur le marché de l'énergie et puis la
transparence et l'information ça a été
souligné par de nombreux acteurs
évidemment il faut la poursuivre elle a
déjà été extrêmement bien développé par
tous les acteurs mais il ne faut pas
l'arrêter pour autant on voit bien que
c'est un sujet qui va se poursuivre dans
le temps qu'il y aura des dos de travaux
d'autres démarrages dans les mois et
dans les années à venir et donc il y a
une nécessité de maintenir ses
rendez-vous réguliers qui se font déjà
au travers du Haut Comité des clips ou
encore au travers de de l'OPEX
aujourd'hui et enfin nous
l'interrogations qu'on se pose c'est de
se dire finalement cette découverte
inattendue et inédit elle
nécessite-t-elle pas d'avoir des
contrôles plus fréquents d'avoir des
maintenances des processus de
surveillance en phythologue plus
fréquente que ce qu'on pouvait faire
jusqu'à aujourd'hui et en tout cas le
vieillissement du parc même si là ça
concerne moins des réacteurs de 900 MW
si je me trompe pas mais en tout cas le
vieillissement du parc peut nous
interroger sur la
fréquence en tout cas de ces contrôles
et de ses surveillance la visite
décennale c'est tous les 10 ans est-ce
que pour des réacteurs de plus de 40 ans
tous les 10 ans c'est la bonne fréquence
en tout cas ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
en terme de sûreté peut nous conduire à
se poser ces questions et à y réfléchir
je vous remercie encore
ce Président si je peux donc terminer
mon l'intervention de l'ampli en
reprenant l'image qui avait développé
dans son propos introductif le président
Longuet de la colline de nucléaire où on
a découvert le phénomène de la corrosion
et pour vous dire que
la question qu'on vient de dire Yves Le
Rheu de savoir si sous cette colline il
n'y a pas d'autres phénomènes
systémiques qui existent et qui pourrait
faire s'effondrer la colline et donc je
voudrais vous exprimer toute
l'inquiétude que nous avons à l'encli
non seulement pour les problèmes que
posent le phénomène de corrosion mais
plus globalement par les enjeux
nucléaires qui se posent à notre pays à
côté des problèmes de soudure de
démantèlement des problèmes de l'EPR qui
n'en finit pas tarder des nouveaux
réacteurs que l'on nous annonce le
vouloir construire rapidement des
piscines des déchets non résolus donc
des enjeux nucléaires énormes et sans
précédent
nous sommes inquiets et nous avons
récemment alerté des responsables
nationaux pour leur dire que selon nous
accélérer des procédures les simplifier
pour gagner quelques mois au motif de
l'urgence pour faire aboutir des projets
dans 15 ans c'est engendré
automatiquement au détriment de la
sûreté une forte pression sur les
exploitants sur l'autorité de contrôle
sur l'expert public qui auront à émettre
des avis dans des délais contraints avec
des ressources humaines qui ne sont
probablement pas suffisantes ou alors je
comprends plus rien
or pour nous la sûreté est une priorité
comme je l'ai dit tout à l'heure il ne
peut pas y avoir de sûreté sous
contrainte
les moyens doivent être assurés il faut
donner les moyens à la SN donner les
moyens des ambitions de la politique
nucléaire française et du vieillissement
de notre part ainsi qu'un l'IRSN et cela
passe aussi par un soutien à
l'expression de la société civile que
nous représentons avec d'autres
structures bien sûr
sur le plan financier à l'expertise que
cette société civile doit pouvoir mener
en disposant aussi de temps pour le
faire car pour nous la société civile
que nous représentons avec d'autres
participent au renforcement de la sûreté
nucléaire
président Longuet a parlé des trois
piliers de la sûreté
l'exploitant l'Autorité de sûreté est
l'IRSN vous me permettrait de rajouter
le quatrième pilier qui est celui de la
société civile à laquelle nous
contribuons
nous sommes inquiets par l'annonce d'un
avant-projet de loi de simplification
des procédures aux motifs de l'urgence
comme je l'ai dit pour des projets dans
15 ans et
nous sommes peut-être le poil à gratter
de que l'on nous reproche d'être
quelquefois mais nous avons l'obligation
dans le cadre de nos missions et du rôle
défoulu par la loi de 2006 et celle de
2015 comme je l'ai indiqué Dieu décret
d'application qui a été pris en 2019 de
faire connaître à nos gouvernants et
donc à vous-même les craintes que nous
pouvons avoir quand elles existent parce
que de vouloir simplifier tout ce
processus avec les problématiques qui ne
manqueront pas de survenir c'est aussi
faire fi des citoyens et c'est donc pour
nous prendre un chemin en inadéquation
avec nos principes de démocratie de
transparence et de participation du
public dans les décisions et c'est
surtout oublier
à nos gouvernants je ne parle pas de
vous en tant que membre du parlement de
respecter les engagements pris par les
gouvernants au niveau du gouvernement
qu'ils ont pris en ce sens il n'y a pas
si longtemps pour nous l'urgence d'une
solution n'est pas une solution
bien je vous remercie
[Musique]
et je vous remercie également de saluer
l'effort que fait l'office depuis de
nombreuses années d'ailleurs pour
s'ouvrir à la société civile vous le
savez c'est important pour nous d'avoir
ces éléments contradictoires et c'est
aussi avec ce type de débat que nous
pouvons ensuite nous appuyer davantage
encore sur l'expertise scientifique et
technique que peuvent nous apporter nos
grandes institutions publiques et c'est
tout l'enjeu de faire émerger à la fois
la science et la société avec une
compréhension commune je laisse donc mes
collègues qui souhaitent s'exprimer je
sais que Stéphane piennoir qui suit
depuis très longtemps ces sujets là
souhaitaient prendre la parole je lui
souhaite de la parole
merci monsieur le Président salut tous
les tous les intervenants et je les
remercie de leurs interventions qui sont
certaines diversité on va dire mais très
très intéressantes je voudrais d'abord
que nous puissions nous féliciter de la
qualité du travail du sérieux ça a été
souligné à plusieurs reprises le sérieux
avec lequel cette histoire a été traitée
a été prise en compte très rapidement
qu'il s'agisse bien sûr de DF mais
l'Autorité de sûreté de l'URSS avec de
nombreux avis on peut toujours regarder
le le pire dans une situation mais on
peut aussi se dire qu'on a des moyens de
contrôle dans notre pays qui sont soit
en commune mesure avec ce que l'on peut
constater dans d'autres pays on peut
aussi de temps en temps sur féliciter et
je voulais le je voulais le souligner
dire aussi que la transparence des
communications
me semble que mettre des avis sur un
site ouvert au public c'est déjà un
grand pas de transparence et je pense
que tout le public qui souhaite se
renseigner s'informer sur ce type une
situation a quand même la possibilité de
de le faire dire aussi l'utilité des
contrôles décennaux sur les sur les
centrales sur les réacteurs les visites
des scénales sont on le voit
programmer pour vérifier un certain
nombre de
tests faire un salon de tests et puis de
temps en temps détecter des choses qui
sont inattendues c'est quand même la
preuve par l'exemple
prof de maths n'aiment pas beaucoup
cette expression enfin c'est quand même
la preuve par exemple que on arrive à
détecter des choses qui sont qui ne
faisaient pas l'objet du test initial
donc là aussi on peut quand même sans
féliciter je partage évidemment la vie
des de tous ceux qui sont exprimés sur
l'absence de marge alors l'absence de
marge sur la sûreté il est en aucune
façon de mon point de vue question de de
réduire les marges de sûreté et je suis
d'accord avec la dernière intervention
monsieur
monsieur Delalande sur le projet de loi
sur le nucléaire au même titre que
l'accélération sur le projet de loi de
l'ENR il me semble qu'on ne peut pas
court-circuiter des documents
d'urbanisme on ne peut pas
court-circuiter des enquêtes publiques
au sol motif de vouloir accélérer encore
faudrait-il savoir sur quelle route on
se trouve
alors sur pour avoir des questions parce
que je sais que le temps est contraint
pour être bien sûr de comprendre
j'aurais savoir pourquoi ce phénomène ne
touche-t-il qu'une partie du parc et sur
des générations de réacteurs nucléaires
différentes on a à la fois sur des
réacteurs assez récents les les 1300 et
aussi sur des sur des très anciens le
premier test a été fait sur un sur un
réacteur plutôt ancien
est-ce qu'il y a eu des changements de
d'utilisation de matériaux de géométrie
on a parlé de géométrie et ce qu'on a
augmenté le nombre de de coûts dans dans
ces installations là je vois être sûr de
bien comprendre deuxième question est-ce
que
on a des conséquences sur les prochains
chantiers les retours d'expérience que
vous avez évoqué également dans d'autres
pays puisque c'est un phénomène
rencontré ailleurs
est-ce que ça aura des conséquences sur
les prochains chantiers je pense en
particulier à l'EPR 2
annoncé comme une simplification d'un
point de vue structurel par rapport à
l'EPR on peut on peut dire tout ce qu'on
veut sur les retards accumulés sur le
père de Flamanville ce qui nous est
proposé il y a pas de signature encore
aujourd'hui mais sur le PA2 on a j'ai
bien entendu et je crois que tout le
monde a bien compris que c'est une
simplification justement des processus
et de la géométrie interne du réacteur
est-ce que ça aura des conséquences donc
sur les solutions techniques dans les
futurs constructions
une autre une autre question sur le
manchage désolé je vais utiliser le
terme propre mais je trouve que c'est il
est plus explicite pour pour les
néophytes le manchonage c'est évidemment
à mon sens une solution moins
invasive que la section et le
remplacement des tuyauteries pourquoi
cette solution n'est pas a priori
retenue comme la plus facile à mettre en
oeuvre et permettant d'avoir un avantage
de visibilité sur la sur la solidité de
la structure autour des soudures en
particulier
est-ce que vous avez des éléments sur la
propagation on dit que la propagation de
ces fissures de corrosion sous
contrainte n'était pas linéaire est-ce
qu'on a néanmoins des des mesures sur la
vitesse de propagation qui pourra
permettre d'anticiper sur sur
d'éventuelles
altérations d'autres d'autres circuits
et donc anticiper des réparations
dernier mot sur alors moi j'ai j'ai
entendu le manque d'investissement
chronique je vais être totalement en
phase avec ça parce qu'effectivement
depuis 30 ans on a un manque
d'investissement mais pas seulement sur
les énergies renouvelables sur le
nucléaire également et on en est rendu
là moi j'ai rien contre les soudeurs
italiens ni américain mais a priori je
leur fais confiance pour faire des
réparations mais on peut effectivement
déplorer qu'en France on est plus ses
compétences sur notre sol on commence à
les retrouver mais ça va ça va prendre
un peu de temps voilà pour être trop
long merci
je vous propose de faire plusieurs
salles de questions il y a également
Philippe bolo qui souhaitait la parole
prendre la parole et puis angélique et
on fera un deuxième tour après ça
permettra de de les questions soient
bien identifiées pour y répondre merci
monsieur le Président merci Monsieur et
Madame pour vous présentation qui sont
éclairantes et je voudrais revenir sur
un point qui suit la temporalité vous
avez clairement expliqué les causes
liées au phénomène de la corrosion sous
contrainte qui peuvent être chimiques
thermiques mécaniques géométriques mais
qu'elle est qu'en est-il de votre
connaissance sur la temporalité je
m'explique entre le moment qu'on qui est
le nôtre qui est le vote surtout de
d'avoir la capacité de détecter une
fissure quel temps sépare ce moment-là
de des premières contraintes cette
capacité de détection peut aboutir si
rien n'est fait vous l'avez clairement
expliqué à des brèches quel est le temps
entre les premières fissures détectables
et les brèches et pourquoi ces questions
là bien parce que il y a deux choses qui
qui me semblent importantes vous faites
des contrôles réguliers donc en
positionne ces contrôles réguliers dans
cette temporalité où est-ce qu'on se
situe est-ce qu'on situe avant la
capacité de détection après ces fissures
apparaissent-elles rapidement ou sur le
long terme donc étant sûr que les
contrôles se font à partir du moment où
les fissures existent ou
apparaîtront-elles juste après le
contrôle vous voyez un peu les notions
qu'il y a derrière et puis également sur
les les remédiations que vous envisagez
les solutions envisagées
je l'ai compris sont un peu le la
réparation à l'identique mais cette
connaissance de la cinétique et de la
temporalité d'apparition des fissures
conditionne le la durée de vie de la
réparation qu'on va mettre en œuvre je
vous remercie
monsieur le Président merci et merci à
vous toutes et tous de vos présentations
très riches très intéressantes alors moi
je vais reprendre quelques questions en
les précisant qui vous ont déjà été
posés c'est justement à propos des
réacteurs de 900 mgawatts qui ne sont
pas visiblement touchés par ces
problèmes de fissuration est-ce que cela
vient de la composition des aciers
puisque les la corrosion donc
induit inoxydation de ces aciers et qui
peut-être viendrait du fait qu'on aurait
changé cette composition est-ce que vous
en avez connaissance vraiment ou pas
autre question sur les soudures et les
réparations de soudure
vous avez vous avez dit qu'elle devrait
être contrôlées car elles impliquent des
contraintes mais c'est quelque chose que
je conçois tout à fait parce que une
soudure supplémentaire
instaure une quelque part et va enchaîne
certainement impliquer d'autres d'autres
contraintes qui n'existaient pas avant
quel est l'ampleur des soudures qui ont
qui ont été opérés sur le parc nucléaire
à quels endroits voilà pour pour plus de
précisions et puis je reprends les
inquiétudes qui ont été formulées
précédemment sur
l'état dans lequel nous sommes sur la
production d'électricité à savoir un
parc nucléaire vieillissant et ça on
pouvait le prévoir tout à fait que les
contraintes mécaniques et on le sait
tous font qu'en vieillissant on a plus
les mêmes qualités et
le fait qu'on n'est pas suffisamment
développé les énergies renouvelables et
le fait que tout à coup on est des
projets de loi qui sont en accélération
sans que on est réactaminé la
programmation pure annuelle de l'énergie
la PPE donc ça c'est vrai que là on a
des phénom enfin de des contraintes pour
nous qui se percutent et qui posent
question
bien monsieur je vous propose de
répondre à cette première salle de de
questions n'hésitez pas également à
rebondir sur les présidents propos qui
ont pu être tenus avant les
parlementaires
que j'ouvre la séquence avec Étienne
Duteil qui directeur du parc nucléaire
complétera un certain nombre d'éléments
merci de ces questions et du temps que
vous consacrez à ce sujet qui est
effectivement tout à fait fondamental je
voudrais quand même redire ce que j'ai
dit en conclusion tout à l'heure qui est
tout à fait clair il n'y a pas
d'arbitrage entre la sûreté et la
sécurité d'approvisionnement
la sûreté est une priorité absolue si
nous avons la moindre conviction
technique ou scientifique qu'un réacteur
se trouve en difficulté nous l'arrêtons
et c'est ce que nous avons démontré très
clairement dans cette crise puisque je
vous rappelle que nous avons pris la
décision d'arrêter une douzaine de
réacteurs alors même que nous étions en
plein hiver donc à un moment où
l'approvisionnement en électricité est
évidemment une question cruciale pour
nos concitoyens donc sur ce terrain là
je récuse le mot d'arbitrage nous serons
toujours d'abord et avant tout au
service de la sûreté
et bien évidemment le second point est
bien celui de la sécurité
d'approvisionnement auquel on est très
attentif plus que plus que jamais dans
ce temps de crise énergétique
mais je tiens à le redire puisqu'il est
absolument fondamental et il nous a
amené à prendre des décisions très
radicales vous le savez
deuxième deuxième remarque qui répond à
quelques-unes des questions qui ont été
posées ou évoqué pourquoi une partie du
parc pourquoi
toutes ces questions sont légitimes je
vous ai dit pour ceux qui nous concerne
nos premières convictions mais avec
humilité c'est à dire qu'il reste encore
beaucoup de travail
y compris de recherche et développement
pour être parfaitement certain d'aboutir
à un consensus scientifique et technique
vue d'EDF la prépondérance le facteur
prépondérant de la création de cette
corrosion sous contrainte c'est bien le
design des lignes
je dis bien que ce n'est pas
nécessairement partagé mais vu de nous
c'est le design des lignes or au regard
de votre interpellation les lignes sont
de plus en plus complexes avec le temps
elles sont plus complexes dans le
dernier palier du N4 que dans le 1300
mégawatts et plus complexe dans le 1300
megawatts que dans le palier 900 MW ce
qui veut de nous est sans doute un
élément d'explication mais il y en a
d'autres j'ai évoqué le sujet de
l'oxygène qui a été évoqué aussi par
l'irsm il va falloir travailler sur ce
plan là et on va mener un certain nombre
d'expertises la question de la
température est évidemment aussi très
importante
et également des typologies de soudure
peut-être à partir desquels on détecte
ce défaut donc tous ces éléments là sont
encore en partie sur la table mais la
prépondérance des lignes vu de nous
conduit à l'explication du fait que oui
nous estimons que le palier
900 MW donc les 32 réacteurs ne sont pas
ou peu affectés par la corrosion sous
contrainte a priori mais vous avez
entendu le hoope donc par rapport je le
dis aussi par rapport à l'idée qu'il n'y
aurait pas de corrosion sous contrainte
sur le païen 900 mégawatts
certainement une affirmation que je ne
partage pas nous avons du travail à
réaliser sur le sujet et nous avons pris
l'engagement vis-à-vis de l'autorité sur
tes nucléaires cela a été rappelé par le
président de rodduc du fait que nous
allions contrôler toutes ces lignes de
tous nos réacteurs y compris de 900
mégawatts d'ici à la fin 2025 simplement
nous avons priorisé sur notre travail
sur les réacteurs qui sont vus de nous
les plus potentiellement affectés c'est
ce qu'on appelle le P prime 4 les 12
réacteurs que j'ai évoqués tout à
l'heure et dans le président de roduc a
redit à l'instant que nous avions pris
l'engagement de les contrôler avant
l'ami 2023 voilà c'est simplement que il
y a sans doute un ordre de priorité qui
est lié vu de nous à la prépondérance
des lignes mais bien sûr que beaucoup de
travail de compréhension reste à faire
ce qui me mène à l'autre sujet qui est
tout à fait fondamental vous l'avez
évoqué c'est la vitesse de propagation
des fissures aujourd'hui nous experts
arrivent à une espèce de vitesse
enveloppe de une propagation de 0,5 mm
par an
cette donnée là n'est pas consensuelle
aujourd'hui elle doit faire encore
l'objet d'un très grand nombre de
travaux sur lesquels nous sommes
concentrés les uns et les autres
évidemment qu'elle est tout à fait
fondamentale pardon tout à fait
fondamental pour avoir la bonne
compréhension de main de la maîtrise de
ce processus
troisième remarque le manchonage
loverlay pour reprendre le mot consacré
dans ce domaine là pourquoi est-ce que
nous ne l'avons pas retenu monsieur
sénateur mais tout simplement parce que
c'est un process qui n'est pas qualifié
dans notre réglementation française
donc nous ne l'excluons absolument pas
c'est ce que j'ai dit peut-être un peu
rapidement tout à l'heure mais
aujourd'hui il n'est pas qualifié or
qualifié
un process de cette ampleur là on parle
bien de cirque auxiliaire au circuit
primaire demande plusieurs mois pour ne
pas dire plusieurs années d'instructions
pour pouvoir aboutir et donc il nous
était impossible de mettre en place
cette technique là au regard de notre
enjeu qui reste bien et c'est le second
la sécurité d'approvisionnement là
évidemment notre objectif c'était bien
de remettre des réacteurs en marche sur
le réseau pour autant nous avons
parfaitement entendu et notamment j'ai
évoqué les experts internationaux que
nous avions invité à Paris notamment de
pri d'ailleurs les Américains qui nous
ont dit mais c'est peut-être un sujet
que vous devriez remettre sur la table
au vu de cette crise c'est un sujet
qu'il faut étudier et donc oui je l'ai
annoncé devant vous nous allons étudier
ce
cette question là de l'overlay et nous
allons bien évidemment engager un
dialogue avec la SN sur la question ça
paraît absolument fondamental voilà ce
que je peux répondre oui sur la présence
de soudeur d'usineurs étrangers je
voudrais être très clair sur deux points
parce qu'il y a beaucoup de confusion là
aussi
premier sujet
nous avions besoin le plus rapidement
possible de fonderie en capacité de nous
préparer des lingots d'inox de qualité
et ensuite de les forger en fonction de
nos spécifications
c'est évidemment une tristesse pour nous
que de ne pas avoir trouvé dans les
temps impartis de fondeur français en
capacité de faire ce travail et donc je
suis très reconnaissant à deux fondeurs
d'Italie du Nord d'avoir répondu présent
et de nous fournir aujourd'hui travail
de très grande qualité
du côté des soudeurs et des usinaires
des tuyauteurs nous avons et le sujet
est parfaitement connu tout le milieu
industriel un déficit très clair dans
cette profession nous avons besoin de
beaucoup de soudeurs de tuyauteurs et
d'usineurs dans notre pays ça c'est
clair c'est la raison pour laquelle le
sujet a été évoqué nous avons par
exemple recréé une école de métier en ce
moment à Cherbourg sur le soudage et il
y en aura d'autres c'est une évidence
parce que nous avons besoin de ces
compétences là donc premier point il y a
un déficit industriel qui ne concerne
pas que l'industrie nucléaire mais qui
est beaucoup plus large le deuxième
point nous l'avons évoqué rapidement
mais qui est très important c'est que ce
sont des travaux qui se font dans un
environnement radioactif avec des
dosimétries importantes et donc il
reçoit que nous respectons non seulement
la réglementation mais en vérité on
prend même une marge par rapport à la
réglementation de la dose acceptable
pour chacun des salariés quels qu'ils
soient EDF ou prestataire qui viennent
travailler évidemment auprès de nous et
il est clair qu'à partir d'un certain
nombre d'heures de travail et bien tout
simplement pour éviter de dépasser la
dose prescrite ces personnes-là doivent
se retirer ce qui est parfaitement clair
nous demande donc une rotation de
personnel tout à fait considérable c'est
à ce titre-là qu'un certain nombre des
groupements qui travaillent avec nous et
que j'ai salué tout à l'heure on fait
appel à une main d'oeuvre étrangère de
grande qualité alors on a parlé beaucoup
d'Américains ou de Canadiens mais on a
aussi beaucoup d'Européens qui sont
venus rapidement à notre à notre secours
pour conforter le travail que nous
souhaitions mener et que nous
souhaitions mener rapidement voilà
pourquoi nous avons fait appel à ce
moment-là mais en vérité il représente
de toute façon cette main d'oeuvre
étrangère moins de 10% des effectifs qui
travaillent à nos côtés notamment en
termes de soudeur de tuyauteur Étienne
est-ce que j'ai oublié ou utiliser
quelque chose peut-être simplement un
point concernant la question de l'âme la
sénatrice sur le l'évolution des
matériaux entre les différentes
générations de réacteurs sommes toujours
restés sur les mêmes matériaux un détail
près mais qui n'intervient pas dans le
cadre de la CSC ce sont toujours des
aciers inoxydables austenitiques qui ont
des propriétés intéressantes de
résistance et de capacité à être soudés
donc le l'évolution des matériaux n'est
pas une explication aujourd'hui qui est
retenue dans le cadre de la CSC et
d'autre part nous n'avons pas non plus
constaté dans nos analyses de déviation
sur les matériaux utilisés par rapport
aux spécifications tous les matériaux
étaient conformes
peut-être un point sur la temporalité
que vous avez évoqué en fait la question
de la temporalité c'est la question de
la périodicité des contrôles de
maintenance or la bien avoir en tête que
la maintenance c'est quelque chose qui
est revisité en permanence en fonction
du retour d'expérience en fonction de ce
qu'on constate sur sur nos installations
avec parfois des allègements si on voit
que la maintenance était où les
contrôles étaient sur abondance ça peut
arriver aussi ou parfois des
approfondissements et là on est vraiment
dans ce cas là si vous constatez que
vous êtes sur une situation qui était
inattendue qui nécessite un renforcement
des opérations de maintenance donc
concrètement sur à la suite de la
découverte de corrosion sous contrainte
nous allons évidemment élaborer un
programme de contrôle adapté à la
surveillance de cette maladie entre
guillemets que nous avons découverte ici
et dont la périodicité va être adaptée à
ce que l'on comprend de la cinétique du
phénomène et de son évolution et ça
c'est encore un sujet en cours d'études
sur le mentionnage loverlay donc il est
lancé EDF où était explorer cette piste
et que la SN nous saisit nous
l'expertiseions un des sujets qui se
rapprochement compliqué c'est le
contrôle des soudures si vous voulez si
vous les entourez c'est plus compliqué
entre les donc ce sera un sujet
important dans un éventuel échange
technique sur les conséquences sur les
futurs chantiers et sur l'avenir donc un
juge de paix c'est vraiment le moyen de
contrôle d'ailleurs ça a des activités
sur lequel il y a ça et une R&D c'est
les moyens de contrôle au-delà de ce
système là sur les installations qui
existent c'est un point essentiel ça
c'est le premier point l'oxygène alors
avec EDF on est d'accord sur la
stratification n'est pas pour l'instant
on n'a pas convaincu EDF de l'importance
de l'oxygène mais je ne désespère pas
d'y arriver et le dernier point c'est
que sur le père et le PR2 les soudures
sont à rasées ce qui est un facteur
favorable d'une part pour l'apparition
des soudures et surtout pour le contrôle
c'est le député Alexandre ça va tout
merci monsieur le Président merci
messieurs pour vos retours et je tiens à
vous féliciter pour la rapidité et la
qualité de traitement de ces incidents
qui doit rassurer les Français notamment
sur votre capacité à gérer des crises
qui comme vous l'avez souligné était
inédite
moi je me pose tout de même une question
c'est y a-t-il un vrai risque ou
avons-nous fait de l'excès de zèle dans
cette gestion de crise à cause notamment
de l'hyper médiatisation des sujets
nucléaires et de la pression que que
vous ressentez à ce titre
qu'en est-il chez nos voisins parce que
donc voilà moi je sais à peu près
comment cela fonctionne l'ASN fait une
analyse rajoute une marge et ensuite
j'ai EDF ou les acteurs travaillant
nucléaires pour que les contrôles avec
la SN se passe bien vous rajoutez
également une marge donc n'en
faisons-nous pas trop ce qui nuirait à
notre productivité en transformant
finalement cet excès de sécurité en une
entrave à notre capacité au niveau au
niveau du nucléaire et donc qu'en est-il
chez nos voisins est-ce que nous sommes
les plus sécuritaires ou est-ce que il
me semble qu'aux États-Unis ils sont un
peu plus souples de ce point de vue là
et donc quel est votre avis sur ce sujet
et pourquoi cette question parce que
dans les documents que vous avez mis à
notre disposition vous avez expliqué que
ces fissures représentées 10% de
l'épaisseur du tuyau
vous avez mentionné l'IRSN la notion de
défaut critique donc justement la
question se pose c'est est-ce qu'il
fallait
du fait que vous expliquez que la
propagation de ces fissures augmente de
quelques millimètres par an enfin de
l'ordre du millimètre par an est-ce
qu'il était nécessaire d'arrêter un
tiers de la production du nucléaire
français pour faire face à cette à cet
incident ou est-ce que on aurait pu
imaginer de lisser justement cette cette
réparation cette gestion de crise pour
limiter ce que nous vivons aujourd'hui
avec
avec la crise la crise énergétique et je
terminerai mon propos
au niveau de la présence de l'Institut
Negawatt donc j'en mets pas en question
du tout
l'existence et
de votre association ou de ce que vous
apportez au débat parce que je pense que
il faut du pour et du contre pour
prendre les meilleures solutions pour
les Français mais je me pose la question
de la présence de cette institut au sein
de cette audition sur ce sujet merci
oui oui oui oui oui oui oui oui oui oui
oui oui
je voudrais relayer un petit peu la
dernière intervention effectivement par
rapport à l'expérience étrangère
est-ce que nos contrôles sont plus
pointus ou est-ce que nos méthodes
nous soudures nos tuyaux ne sont pas les
mêmes qu'à l'étranger
parce qu'on sait bien qu'en France et en
tout cas sous la houlette de la SN et
des RSN on a une grande fiabilité de la
sûreté
mais d'essayer de comprendre mais vous
nous l'avez bien dit
que c'était pas évident de savoir quel
était la raison entre le métal entre les
usages et autres et j'ai simplement une
question qui me qui demeure mais c'est
pour c'est pour Monsieur Lewandowski
vous aviez vous avez parlé de la a
posteriori des contrôles sur 10 ans
est-ce que ça vous a révélé quelque
chose et est-ce que c'est une pratique
habituelle
moi je me souviens d'audition ici sur
des problèmes de soudure des cuves c'est
pas les premières fois que sur des
centrales nucléaires on se penche sur le
problème des soudures
et est-ce que cette relecture est
habituelle et est-ce qu'elle nous a
est-ce qu'elle vous a en tout cas
auparavant apporté quelque chose merci
je m'associe aux remerciements
enthousias intervenants et puis
particulièrement aussi à l'office pour
développer cette transparence dans le
nucléaire attendez besoin parce que tout
repose sur la confiance si vous
permettez je vais aller un peu plus loin
en tant que membre de la commission
défense est-ce que les installations
embarquées de notre marine et c'est Naïs
est né le porte-avion Charles de Gaulle
connaisse les mêmes problèmes sachant
que c'est pas les mêmes géométrie du
tout et puis si ils connaissent pas ce
type de problème à ma connaissance c'est
le cas
quelles leçons pour nous tirer pour vos
installations et puis surtout le
développement des petites unités
nucléaires que le Président de la
République a évoqué comment elle peut
trouver sa place dans le mix énergétique
et que vous développez à EDF
un petit peu du cadre de la corrosion
sous contrainte mais ce sera intéressant
quand même d'avoir une perspective vous
avez raison d'en profiter de leur
présence
peut-être si vous voulez reprendre la
parole
merci nouveau pour pour toutes ces
questions peut-être commencer par la
question de madame la sénatrice sur la
relecture a postériori tout simplement à
partir du moment où nous étions
confrontés sur six vaut 1 à un phénomène
que nous ne comprenions pas
qui n'était pas conforme à ce que nous
disposons dans notre
référentiel
il nous a paru intéressant d'aller
fouiller dans l'ensemble de nos archives
pour essayer de retrouver des notations
et on appelle ça nous des indications
des signaux éventuellement atypiques qui
auraient pu être éventuellement
signifier dans toutes les années
précédentes lors des visites décennales
sur l'ensemble du parc est-ce que nous
le faisons régulièrement oui est-ce que
nous le faisons avec cette ampleur non
effectivement la particularité c'est
qu'on est allé voir l'ensemble c'est des
dizaines de gens qui ont été mobilisés
pour aller Reda tailler l'ensemble de
nos archives est-ce que ça a été utile
oui bien sûr puisque c'est justement ce
travail documentaire qui nous a permis
de définir très précisément les sept
réacteurs complémentaires aux quatre
premiers et à panlien que j'évoquais
tout à l'heure pourquoi parce que sur
ces 7 réacteurs faire nous ont dit nous
estimons que les notes prises les
indications qui ont pu être vues à
l'époque
ressemblent à ce que nous pensons voir
si vous donc à nouveau il n'y a pas de
vérité révélée nous sommes à l'époque
dans un moment où il faut bien prendre
les éléments dont on peut disposer face
à un phénomène inconnu mais ça a été
effectivement extraordinairement utile
et ça renvoie à nouveau accessoirement à
la qualité des archives de la de la
maison et la manière dont la traçabilité
de l'ensemble de nos outils et non
seulement nécessaire mais vraiment
extrêmement
utile et nous a permis d'apporter ces
éléments donc grâce soit rendu à tous
ceux qui contribuent à cette traçabilité
sur la question très précise des
installations
embarquées du côté de la défense sachez
que nous avons évidemment des contacts
réguliers qu'ils ont été informés de
l'ensemble de nos travaux maintenant je
permettrai de vous renvoyer à eux comme
vous êtes à la commission
idoine pour leur poser la question mais
nous sommes dans une situation qui est
très très différente donc difficilement
comparable mais le travail a été fait
d'échange sur le plan sur le plan
technique soyez-en assurés peut-être
Étienne sur la dimension internationale
qui a pu être évoqué le partage oui
depuis le début de la crise corrosion
sous contrainte j'ai des échanges avec
mes homologues plus particulièrement
avec mes homologues en Europe d'ailleurs
sur le sujet que j'ai tenu régulièrement
informé nous avons des réunions qui me
permettent de faire cela
je les ai tenu informé à la fois de
l'évolution de la crise chez nous mais
aussi de nos premières conclusions
puisque ça ça leur permet aussi de
nourrir leur propre réflexion je pense
en particulier à ce que nous avons
détecté sur l'influence du design qui
peut les réinterroger les amener à
prioriser et puis tout récemment le j'ai
eu l'occasion de le faire cette fois-ci
avec une dans le cadre du d'une réunion
mondiale des exploitants ou donc les
organisateurs avaient sollicité EDF pour
faire une présentation complète sur le
dans le domaine de la corrosion sous
contrainte donc il y a bien un partage
entre les différents exploitants chacun
traitant le sujet dans le cadre
réglementaire qui est le sien et qui
conditionne une grande partie de la
suite des événements
par rapport à la question de l'excès de
zèle que vous avez posé monsieur le
député c'est une question
très clairement légitime mais nous avons
eu le sentiment au contraire d'être les
plus pragmatiques
possible avec toujours un seul principe
pardon de le répéter mais qui est que la
priorité absolue est bien celle de la
sûreté à partir de là quand vous êtes
confronté un défaut que vous ne
connaissez pas qui est dans un circuit
auxiliaire du circuit primaire dans un
lieu qui est évidemment très particulier
dans une centrale nucléaire la moindre
des choses c'est de prendre le maximum
de précaution et nous pensons avoir eu
raison de le faire avec le recul du
temps
pas simplement au nom du principe mais
tout simplement parce que la la taille
et la profondeur d'un certain nombre de
fissures notamment quand elles sont sur
l'ensemble de la circonférence renvoie à
des analyses de sûreté qui doivent être
très clairement remises sur le métier
c'est le travail que nous sommes en
train de faire tous ensemble avec avec
la SN et l'IRSN donc non nous n'avons
pas eu le sentiment d'en avoir trop fait
au contraire pense qu'on a essayé de
mesurer nos efforts au regard de la
politique de sûreté telle qu'elle nous
apparaissait absolument essentielle par
ailleurs la réglementation française et
qui est de bonne aloi dit que sur ces
tuyauteries là on admet pas de défaut on
admet pas d'aléa et ça paraît aussi
assez naturel que de pouvoir garantir à
nos concitoyens que lorsqu'on approche
le circuit primaire on a affaire un
matériel qui est dans un état
d'exception je tiens à vous rassurer un
tiers de l'appareil de production n'a
pas été arrêté du fait de la corrosion
sous contrainte il se trouve qu'en ce
moment
c'est ainsi les sujets se cumulent nous
avons en parallèle un programme
considérable qui est le grand carénage
qui nous permet de passer de 40 à 50 ans
comme vous savez
de vie pour une partie de nos vecteurs
en tout cas le 900 mégawatts et que ces
travaux conduisent effectivement la raie
durable près de 6 mois de
d'un grand nombre de nos réacteurs
justement du fait de ce de ce grand
carénage qui a commencé maintenant
depuis deux ans donc c'est bien le cumul
de travaux tout à fait considérable sur
le grand carénage qu'on appelle post
Fukushima donc les vd4 du 900 MW plus la
corrosion sous contrainte qui nous a
amené à cette perte de productible qui
est tout à fait considérable il s'agit
certainement pas de de la relativiser
mais qui nous conduit à prévoir
effectivement cette année un productible
de l'ordre 280 à 300 TW pour l'année
sur la question des SMS peut-être très
rapidement puisque c'était votre
question un peu indépendante de notre
sujet
nous pensons au regard de l'ensemble des
analyses internationales de l'Agence
internationale de l'énergie et de
l'Union européenne qui toute convergent
pour dire que l'électricité va connaître
des courbes de croissance tout à fait
considérable notamment du fait de
nouveaux usages dans les années qui
viennent que nous aurons besoin de toute
l'électricité des carbonées possible
donc on l'a dit bien sûr dans le domaine
renouvelable c'est pas notre sujet
aujourd'hui nous le pensons également
dans le domaine nucléaire c'est la
raison pour laquelle EDF propose de
prolonger la durée de vie de ces
centrales et il travaille je l'évoquais
à l'instant c'est le grand carénage
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
déposé un dossier auprès du gouvernement
au printemps 2021 proposant la
construction de 6 OPR 2 vous le savez
également mais également nous pensons
que les petits réacteurs les SMS
pourraient être un complément
extrêmement utile à fois l'international
mais y compris chez nous pour un certain
nombre d'usages dans les années qui
viennent nous avons créé un consortium
avec technicatum avec le CEA avec
naval group pour concevoir un réacteur
de 170 MW électrique et nous espérons
proposer un design au gouvernement de ce
sms qu'on a appelé new Award en 2023
donc une course est lancée autour des
SMS qui nous paraissent effectivement
une voie d'avenir extrêmement
intéressante pour le nucléaire français
merci monsieur le Président oui moi je
voudrais revenir sur sur la question à
la fois de la
du plan d'investigation et essayer
d'apporter une réponse monsieur député à
votre question sur l'excès Deux Alpes
potentiel je crois que nous avons essayé
les uns et les autres de bien expliquer
à la fois le caractère totalement inédit
par rapport au parc mondial de la
découverte de corrosion sous contrainte
mais également le fait que EDF ne
disposait d'aucun moyen au moment où la
découverte a été faite pour caractériser
la taille de la fissuration autrement
dit nous étions en aveugle pendant à peu
près un semestre il était même pas
envisageable d'imaginer de demander à
EDF de justifier le maintien en service
des réacteurs puisqu'on ne savait pas
quels étaient les circuits affectés
quels étaient les tailles de défauts
potentiels et qu'elles étaient les
marges par rapport un risque de rupture
on savait simplement que ce phénomène
était présent sur des circuits non Isola
par rapport au circuit primaire et comme
je l'ai dit dans mon propre polyminaire
qu'en cas de rupture nous étions face à
un accident nucléaire donc pendant 6
mois nous sommes en aveugle et il était
absolument indispensable de mener les
investigations qui nécessitaient des
découpes puisque pas de moyens de
contrôle pour pouvoir expertiser
identifier quel était l'ampleur des des
dégâts si je peux prendre ce terme sur
l'ensemble du parc nucléaire d'où la
période d'investigation qui a été menée
nous sommes dans une deuxième phase à
partir de maintenant sommes dans une
phase où grâce au travail
d'investigation en profondeur qui a été
menée un ordre de priorité a été défini
que nous avons reconnu comme étant
acceptable au regard des justifications
sur les facteurs prépondérants de
développement de cette corrosion liée
aux géométrie des lignes et par rapport
à la question qui est posée tout à
l'heure mais pourquoi donc cette
situation ne sait pas trouver sur
d'autres types de réacteurs voire à
l'étranger c'est parce que effectivement
la géométrie des lignes des lignes en
question à évoluer à travers le temps
avec le palier très simple puis à
travers le palier de 4 il n'y a à bas
connaissance pas de réacteur dont le
monde avec des géométries de ligne
comparables à celle que nous avons sur
le réacteur très simple le recteur N4 il
faut le vérifier mais aujourd'hui c'est
très différent les réacteurs les plus
répandus à eau sous pression sont dans
des conceptions comparables au réacteurs
de 900 mégawatts que nous avons en
France qui sont de conception
Westinghouse et ce sont les réacteurs
les plus anciens qui ont 40 ans et qui
ne sont pas ou peu affectés donc on voit
bien ce n'est pas un phénomène lié au
vieillissement la question n'est pas de
savoir si parce que les installations
vieillissent ce phénomène de se
développer non il peut se développer
rapidement sur des réacteurs qui sont
relativement récents les réacteurs N4
ont 20 ans donc voyez-vous nous étions
dans une première période dans un peu
dans le noir et il fallait absolument
que ce plan soit développé écran
parallèle une technique de contrôle non
destructive qui reste encore à améliorer
et à qualifier puisse nous permettre de
mettre en œuvre la stratégie qui a été
développée par des c'est la phase dans
laquelle nous nous trouvons nous sommes
maintenant en mesure d'accepter la
priorisation qui a été proposée par EDF
et bien évidemment comme je l'ai dit
également en fonction des résultats qui
seront découverts liés à ces
investigations peut-être cette stratégie
de contrôle et vous le rappelle c'est
encore possible nous sommes loin d'avoir
fait le tour de cette question
quelle réactions par rapport à ce
phénomène à l'étranger comme je l'ai dit
nous avons présenté à nos homologues
étrangers la situation et je peux vous
dire qu'aucun d'entre eux qu'aucun
d'entre eux n'a estimé que nous avions
fait collectivement EDF qui a pris
toutes les décisions mises à l'arrêt et
la SN d'excès de l ils auraient fait la
même chose dans leur pays si les
fissurations n'ont pas de 10%, mais
parfois du quart de l'épaisseur avait
été découvertes on est parfois avec
quasiment aucune marge par rapport à la
taille du défaut critique qui pourrait
entraîner en cas de sollicitations du
réseau du circuit pardon d'injection de
sécurité une rupture hop ça a été bien
n'est présenté au début on est dans un
circuit qui est d'une certaine manière
passif au démarrage on ne l'utilise pas
en fonctionnement normal de
l'installation en revanche si on en a
besoin pour faire face à une brèche
primaire il faut pouvoir injecter de
manière rapide une quantité importante
d'eau pour pouvoir alimenter le cœur et
l'activation du coeur
si dans une telle hypothèse parce que il
y aurait forcément un choc froid il y
aurait
une amenée rapide d'eau à une
température plus froide que la
température du cœur la se choque froide
avec une tuyauterie qui comporterait des
fissurations pouvant aller jusqu'au
quart de l'épaisseur pourrait seront
donc c'est un véritable sujet sérieux
important en termes de sûreté et il faut
distinguer dans notre analyse les deux
phases les premiers six mois qui étaient
nécessaires en termes d'investigation
qui ont fait l'objet également de la
part d'EDF de justification en termes de
tenue mécanique en termes ça a été dit
par l'IRSN de justification de capacité
à replier le réacteur en cas de rupture
de deux ligneries avec un certain nombre
de marge de d'aggravants pardon
permettant de le justifier également des
mesures de surveillance en exploitation
c'est ce bouquet cet ensemble de
justification qui ont été fournies par
EDF au cours du premier semestre qui
vous conduit à accepter le maintien en
service des réacteurs sans excès
prudence
ensuite ce que je voudrais dire par
rapport à la question du de du débat
entre
potentiel entre sécurité et
d'alimentation électrique et sûreté à
aucun moment à aucun moment nous n'avons
pris de décision nous n'avons validé des
propositions d'ef en prenant en compte
le risque de
d'alimentation électrique nous avons
pris des décisions
proportionnées qui ont été toutes
justifiées par des ondes de sûreté si
EDF n'avait pas pris les décisions
qu'ils ont prises et si nous avions
estimé qu'il y avait un enjeu de sûreté
nous aurions demandé à l'exploitant de
mettre à l'arrêt les réacteurs ça me
paraît tout à fait clair notre position
sont proportionnées aux enjeux mais
elles ne sont à aucun moment en
situation d'arbitrage et je pense que
collectivement mettre en débat la
question de l'arbitrage entre la
sécurité d'alimentation électrique et la
sûreté nucléaire ne serait absolument
pas une position qui serait tenable qui
serait acceptable parce que la sûreté
doit être considérée comme étant un bien
commun et aucun acteur qu'il s'agisse du
gouvernement de l'exploitant ou des
publics ne peut soutenir l'idée qu'il
faille faire un arbitrage entre les deux
parce que c'est une question de remise
en cause totale du contrôle de la
confiance pardon dans le contrôle du
nucléaire si on allait dans cette voie
chez de La Londe
oui monsieur le Président moi aussi je
voudrais rebondir sur l'interrogation je
ne
nous interventions comme une
interrogation sur l'éventuelle excès de
zèle de nos partenaires pour vous
signaler que je me félicite de la
réponse qui est apportée par Monsieur
Lewandowski au titre d'EDF parce que je
me souviens qu'il y a quelques années
j'avais été invité avec des mêmes
personnes non pas en nom mais en
structure représentée par la commission
de l'Assemblée nationale sur les petites
n'y avait-il pas eu un excès de zèle sur
le plan économique de la décision prise
par le président chevet à l'époque de
faire arrêter en pleine période d'hiver
des installations nucléaires et la
question était posée par EDF
je ne me rappelais plus le nom de celui
qui représentait monsieur dewandowski et
nous avions été unanime à dire que non
que ces contrôles étaient nécessaires et
comme vous les députés nous avaient posé
la question mais pourquoi est-ce qu'on
fait en France alors que c'est pas fait
aux États-Unis ailleurs
effectivement pourquoi sur ce n'est pas
fait aux États-Unis et ailleurs et on a
rebondi sur la question qu'un accident
nucléaire avant Fukushima ça ne pouvait
pas arriver est-ce que vous êtes sûr que
demain un accident nucléaire n'arrivera
pas dans notre pays et si
l'interrogation que je prends comme tel
et j'espère que ce n'est pas au fond de
vous-même ce que vous souhaiteriez que
nous ayons un expert public un
exploitant à
responsable un gendarme de la sûreté
ferme les yeux et n'exige pas
je suis je ne vous provoque pas mais si
si tel était éventuellement votre
question est-ce que vous seriez à ce
moment-là à ma question à même d'assumer
la responsabilité et votre culpabilité
d'avoir laissé passer un accident
donc je suis persuadé que vous avez même
interrogations que nous pour savoir si
on en fait pas trop si on en fait pas
assez mais de faire en sorte que on
fasse tout ce qu'il est nécessaire de
faire pour que la sûreté soit maintenue
ne se dégrade pas et se développe et je
pense qu'on est tous d'accord
mais je crois que notamment au vu des
propos qu'adules présidents de l'ASN la
réponse a déjà été donnée avec cette
garantie qu'on peut avoir et notamment
en termes de prévention à la sûreté
nucléaire c'est le député
je tenais juste à proposer légèrement
mes propos
en fait j'ai mal peut-être mal posé ma
question
cette question là n'était pas forcément
axée sur la gestion de crise qui avait
eu parce que j'ai travaillé dans
l'industrie je sais que comment ça
marche de ce point de vue là mais
c'était plus également plus général pas
forcément sur ce sujet là si
cette sécurité qui peut paraître
excessive ou non qui est justifié ou non
n'entrave pas notre productivité et ben
voilà vous avez vous avez très bien
compris merci
monsieur Marignac oui merci monsieur le
Président quelques quelques commentaires
courts d'abord sur cette question de
d'un arbitrage entre sûreté et sécurité
moi je maintiens que de façon implicite
il s'applique aujourd'hui la SN
d'ailleurs à par le passé dans certaines
décisions pas celles qui concerne ce
dossier fait état dans ces considérants
de l'impératif de sécurité électrique et
quand monsieur leswandowski dit que la
sûreté est une priorité absolue certes
ça ne veut pas dire que la sûreté est un
critère absolu on relativise en
permanence on proportionne comme vient
de le dire monsieur le président de
l'ASN les décisions et actuellement je
considère qu'elles sont proportionnées
en ayant en tête la pression qui exerce
la sécurité électrique et des propos
comme ceux récents du ministre de
l'économie appelant à ce que EDF
redémarre à tout prix
ces réacteurs avant l'hiver
sur
la question
la question du mentionnage alors oui il
est pas qualifié etc je voulais juste
rappeler que en fait ça n'était pas une
option actuellement en tout cas tant que
la stratégie consistait à
faire des examens destructifs donc à
devoir réparer de toute façon les coudes
en revanche c'est effectivement une
option j'ai vraiment j'ai aucun avis à
ce stade sur elle mais c'est une option
qui peut répondre à la préoccupation que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure de d'apporter
une réponse pérenne à long terme
vis-à-vis du risque de réapparition de
ce phénomène
sur sur le dernier point sur la question
de de la temporalité ou de l'apparition
sur les paliers 900 yawatts je voudrais
par exemple rappeler que le cas détecté
sur un palier 900 MW et dû apparemment à
la présence d'un micro défaut sur une
soudure qui n'avait pas été détecté ce
qui nous incite là encore à prendre en
compte le fait que des écarts qui a
priori ne sont pas jugés importants
jusqu'ici peuvent le devenir au vu de
nouveaux phénomènes et sur la
temporalité ben on a un retour
d'expérience grâce à au 115 découpes
réalisées par EDF et aux analyses qui
peuvent être faites en détail sur les
les
fissures apparentes sur la vitesse à
laquelle ça s'est propagé et formé ça ne
dit rien ou en tout cas ça ne dit pas
tout de la vitesse à laquelle de
nouvelles fissures pourraient se
propager dans des équipements qui ont
entre-temps vieilli qui ont subi toutes
les sollicitations qu'ils ont connu donc
il y a encore une fois beaucoup de de
prudence à avoir vis-à-vis de ça tout
dernier point ça m'amène à un
commentaire sur le projet de loi
d'accélération nucléaire qui a été
évoquée à plusieurs reprises non pas sur
la partie nouveaux réacteur qui est une
certaine manière hors sujet pour notre
discussion aujourd'hui mais sur les
articles 8 et 9 de mémoire qui concerne
le nucléaire existant et explicitement
dans l'exposé des motifs le fait de
sécuriser juridiquement la prolongation
des réacteurs existants je pense qu'on a
là une orientation ou une intention qui
peut aller contre la prudence à laquelle
nous appelle le dossier dont on parle
aujourd'hui alors en complément
également des questions du public qui
nous ont été transmises il y a notamment
un sujet qui revient
il y aurait eu des révélations notamment
dans dans la presse de le premier cas de
corrosion sous contrainte
dès 1984
concernant le circuit ris du du
troisième réacteur de Buguet est-ce que
là dessus vous pouvez nous nous éclairer
pour justement bien remettre les choses
en perspective et notamment vous l'avez
rappelé le phénomène inattendu et inédit
de la corrosion sous contrainte pour
éclairer là aussi l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens
j'ai effectivement évoqué d'ailleurs
dans mon propos liminaire le fait qu'un
en 1983 effectivement à budget nous
avions découvert une trace de corrosion
sous contrainte mais qui était liée à
une pollution je vais laisser Étienne de
préciser
oui c'est exactement cela c'est à dire
que c'est cette fois-ci une corrosion
sous contrainte qui était liée à
l'existence d'un milieu extrêmement
agressif pour pour l'acier inoxydable
qui concrètement j'ai essayé d'être
simple dans l'explication mettez lié au
fait que vous aviez une tuyauterie à
l'intérieur duquel le niveau d'eau avait
baissé le n'était plus complètement
rempli d'eau vous avez une partie d'eau
liquide et une partie de vapeur et à
l'interface entre la vapeur et l'eau
vous avez une concentration de polluants
puisque en l'occurrence ils étaient
présents dans l'eau qui a attaqué la
synoxydable et créer des conditions
favorables à l'apparition au
développement d'une grossion sous
contrainte donc c'est bien un élément
que nous avions en tête on n'a jamais
dit que la corrosion sous contrainte
était inattendue elle est inattendue à
l'endroit où on l'a trouvé si beau et ce
retour d'expérience était connu
très bien merci pour ce pour ce rappel
donc c'était un phénomène plutôt
chimique là où aujourd'hui ce serait un
phénomène plus plutôt physique pour un
résumé était plutôt le la partie milieu
rappelez-vous toujours le triptyque
matériaux milieu contrainte la cause
prépondérante ici dans la majorité des
cas et il faut être prudent ce serait
plutôt la partie contrainte
bien écoutez je crois que nous allons
pouvoir conclure nos notre avant nous
travaux on va vous remercier pour
l'ensemble de vos propos très clairs qui
nous permettent de bien comprendre à la
fois les enjeux je sais aussi on aura
beaucoup d'impatience à à débattre aussi
par la suite avec notamment les nouveaux
équipements qui qui arriveront et en
tout cas là en la phase de projet de loi
évidemment l'Office sera présent pour
pouvoir étayer et scientifiquement et
technologiquement l'ensemble des enjeux
qui sont devant nous donc un grand merci
à vous pour votre participation et je
lève maintenant la séance